Hello guys welcome. In this video, the guys
Creating a job management project
I am using Nexis 16 and Super Bass. So
Guys having his own front end in the Nexis 16
Going to do. And for the back end we use
We will make our super base where all our
There are data stores. where all of
There may be jobs, all applications may be
Can. All users can be. Now
Here this will be our simple home page.
This is simple static data. Right now we have on this
Nothing has been done on the home page. But
When he logs in, for example, I
I say I'm getting started here.
If he clicks on sign in then here
Pay aayega and he can sign in here
Is. If suppose he could be a recruiter or
So he may be a job seeker. if he
If there is a recruiter then he can post the job.
If he is a job seeker then he will look at all the jobs.
Can. Can filter. Also apply
Can. So these are all the guys we have here
There are people who make pay. So if I were to tell someone right now
I log in with an email and if I say
Job Seeker and I sign here
Am. So here if I sign with Job Seeker
If I do this, I can see it here.
What is the status of my application?
I can filter here according to
To date. I'm here at My Jobs
I can go. I see all the jobs here
I can. I can tell from the title.
I can check the location. And then I
Here if I look at the job details further
I can see more details of the job if I want.
Am. I can close it. Also apply
I can. Upload your resume from here
I will do it. Whatever I put in my cover letter,
I will send a message. I will apply then. So
I can do all this. and then our
When we applied for the application here
If that has happened, you can submit your application here also.
You can see. You can also check its status.
And you can see all the details. and then you
Your profile is simple here.
It is ours. So you can see that now
The data we have in our profile
We can see the date. If here already
All this would have been uploaded. Here you
The check is not visible here. So you have some
It looks like this. So these guys we are
There are makers. And this is a job seeker. If
If this were a recruiter, you would have a little
I could see some different things. Ok? So this
Guys we are going to make it. And if any
I was a recruiter, so if I were to log in with the recruiter
I log out from here.
And I log in with the recruiter.
Let's sign in. And if we
If you log in here with the recruiter
Here you will see how many applications there are.
Its. How many jobs have they posted?
If you haven't posted a job, you can do so here.
You can post jobs on this. post a job
You can. All these fields will be chosen which
That you can post jobs here. End
Please post all your posts here.
You can see all that here. own
You can see the profile and then you can see it here
You can log out. So when you log out
So you will come to the home page here. End
Then you will see a view like this. So
These guys, we are going to make one. End
For this we are going to use here
These are Nex 16 and Super Bass. so guys please
Like the video, subscribe to the channel
to do. So let's go guys and get this started
We do. So here come the guys and
One of yours here on the next one first
Let's create a project. So one job
We do. Let's go to the terminal and end here
But let's clear this up.
And here mx create next app at
latest and because I need to have it in this folder
Have to create. So what will we do
Here? Simple Dot So what will it do? This
In the folder where our terminal point
It is right there. And it is saying that we
Accepting all the defaults
Is. So I say yes. So whatever this
It will take the default settings. End
Whatever packages there are, there is a tail wind in it.
Everything here: Install TypeScript
All the installation will be done in this. Ok?
Then what will we do here? set your own
We will also add CN here.
Ok? So let's come here. till then
They say we have set CN here. set
CN is U. Ok? So set CN to us
People add here. so from him
Our UI will be much better and we will
In making people. Ok? So here you are
You can see the components etc. And here
Let's go to the docks. Docs Pe Hum
What are people going to do? In the next Jas.
So let's come here. So what is this saying?
that if you have this set in next js
If you want to add them, you should run this command.
Will have to. So if you are doing PA from PNPM
Then you can run this command. Taxes from NPM
If you are living then you can do this with your friend.
So accordingly. So what am I here for?
Will I do it? Copy your command with npm
I will do it. And if it has happened here then
I will paste it here. so what is this
Will he? Here's our set CNB here, this
Asking what kind of theme do you want to keep?
So I am calling it natural. If I
If you want to change the theme, we will do that too.
People will do it. Ok? So I did this
Took. Ok? And come here. End
Here you can see whatever component you
You have to use this for example
That button add here let's go to the component.
Whichever component of this you now
If you want to use it, what can you do for it?
Simply click on it here. and this
He will tell you and will also give you commands. Look here
This command has been given. Just what you have to do
Is? For example, I have to do a task
Are. Let's take the simple one with buttons. So here
button. Ok? So here's the button. So this
He is telling. You can either copy this and make your own
Create the component and place it there. Or else
Here you simply run this command and
Let's do this on the new tunnel. oh this is the one
We already have it. So I'm here with this
I will add it. So what will he do?
here here you will see it sorry here
But where did our component go here?
It was made because now they have made this SRC
Removed because now app routing is also here
It works right here in the app.
Here at the level here it has the component
Created a folder and here it created a UI
Created a folder inside it and inside it
You will find all the components added here.
We will now focus on this component.
You will have complete control here.
Okay, so in the same way, if you assume that I
Input has to be added here. So if I
Where is the input here? a form
The input is like this. So if I were to
There is input. So if I simply add this
I will give
So if you look here, the input is also here
It will be added and come here, whatever it takes
Related: Look here, our input guy has come.
Near. And all these components which have
I have styles if I want to change them.
If I want to add any class then we will do that also.
People can do it here now. Ok? So
So what can we do here?
Are? Add the Sets Chain to your project
Can. And how can I use it?
We already saw it. Ok? So use it now
How to do it? Because this is a component.
So what can you do simply? So here
Come and see, they have exported it.
to the button. So what can you do simply?
Wherever you want to use it, walk into the app
Are. Let's go to the page here. And here
Pay simple remove it. Now Maine is here
But let's remove this also. And simple you
What is the plan? This component import
Have to do it. And where from? So from here to here
This is our UI end within the component itself.
Button end is self close. Self-conscious. Correct
Is? And sorry, let's remove it from here.
And if you look here, we will run it.
We do it. So let's go here on our
And here we call it
Clear and PM run devp. Ok? So this
Our project will also run. And this
Our project is running here.
Is. So let's copy this. And here
Let's paste this. So here
If you see, our project is also running here.
Will be done. The end is perfect. Ok? So
We make it dark mode. So
Here is our ah, look here this button ah
Went. So now let's do one thing, we have pressed the button.
But what do we do here?
Will it have to? So we also need some text in the button.
So you have to give it. For example, here I am
Let me tell him click me. Ok? This
So now inside this you can tell which
Type variant. Like look at this, come now
Went. Now I have to change its theme. So
How can they do that? So let's do one thing.
Let's go here. So if you come here
You have the option of customization here
will get. Let's go to our A section here.
Pay. So if you look here, you will see here
You will get the theme. Ok? Like it's natural
Is. So which one should you do? Keeping Orange
Is it, should I keep it red or keep it everyday? So everyday
The one looks right. So we have it here
Now let's copy this. so what is this
Are you saying? We need to specify the global dot CSS in the app
Go and keep it. So I copy this
Am. And let's go to our place. And I
Here it goes into global dot CSS
Am. And I will paste it here.
Give. I will remove this and then remove the root one.
I don't want the root one. So I simply
I will put this in the root one. Ok? So
We don't want the dark one either because it
We already have it. So we have this theme
Have to use it. So I'm going to use this one.
Ok? So I think now being perfect
Needed So look at this theme of ours.
The application has been done. And Hum Log Yeh Wala Theme
are going to use through out their
Application. Ok? perfect. We people make this
Let's do it, Claus. And this is how we saw it
We can use it here. Correct
Is? Let's close this too. So what do we
Have to do it? So I'm going to use a component here.
Let me create a shared folder here.
Ok? A either do one thing like this
I make a component here, we
Pay your header.
Ok? So I'm saying header here.
dot psx. Ok? So what are we here for?
Are you going to do it? We're going to create our header.
So here I say cost header. Correct
Is? And here we will tell our
Whatever the return we need to keep the header. of now
That's why I am saying here D. And I
I am saying header here. Welcome to my
Website like this. Ok? And I'm here
What will I do with it? export default own
Header. So now we can put it here wherever
We have to use this header, we can use
Are. Correct? Similarly, we are here
You can also create your own footer. Correct? so one
Work: So here first we do one thing.
Are. This is what I call use client. This
I create the client component.
Because what happens in Nex is the default
Are there? All servers are components.
So what did I do here? This is the client
Made the component. What do I do now?
Here we will do one more thing.
Will keep the logo and sign up. Ok? here
What do we do? We first do this
We will make it a header. Ok? We are here
Let's use the header tag. In this
I say class. So here we are
This will be the class name. Correct Class
Name. Ok? Sorry. o a class name
Class name. Ok? So here we are
You can use the class name of Telbin.
Correct. I say sticky here. Correct
Is? And I call it zero from the top.
I call it width, full border.
I call it bottom border rose because we
What themes are people using there?
Rose theme correct. So here I am saying
Yes, I say 200 every day. BG White Cahn
Let's give it and give it some kind of opacity.
Let me make it 95. back drop blur
We do it. Let's call it support.
back
Drop flutter and I call it BG
White and 60 make it opacity
In. Ok? So
It is saying something like error. So it is saying
Can be written. Ok? Ok. So let's do one thing
Yes, let us keep it like this. So I
I will remove this. And I simply like this
I will keep it. Ok? So this will be mine
What are you saying to me? Children element.
Ok? We will see to that. A here
I What do we say? to this one
Let us take the div. Ok? So I
Here I say class name container
We give a little bit from Max Auto Px x
sa padding x from left right so we guys
Here it is said that in four and when small
If it goes then I will tell it to be px a six
I will give him a six like this, I will fix him.
When a little bit goes into a large one then
What can we do in large px
I can increase it a little bit, I can increase it
okay so this is kind of like this
What is the end point
Normally what do you do in CSS?
You write to the media. But here you are here
Pe isi samaj se SM, MD, LG us pe jaake
You can set your own class. Ok? So this
I did it. And here we say
Here is the link, from here we will go to the next link
The link will be imported. Ok? And here
Pe hum log a HRF denge usko. Firstly
Let's give HRF. HRF I say
Blank for now. Here I say
This is due. So I'll make it quickly
I am a leader because right now we are not in this
In a way, back etc. do not work here.
Are going to do it. Simple HTML is quick
I make it from scratch, otherwise it will take more time.
It will work. Ok? Sign in. Ok? So we
People here, should I sign this up? Now look
This is the button. Ok? So if this button is
How do we route to any page on this?
do? So what can you do here simply?
yes? You can use the link component. Correct
Is? So I'm saying here's the link.
Inside the component button itself. Ok? And I
I am wrapping it up. Ok? And here
But what will we say? HRF. So HR
In the app, we log here wherever we have to log in
Whether to send it to these or wherever it is to be sent
You can send it. Ok? So I again
class here quickly I can use this
I take classes etc. Ok? So like this
What will happen to me here? Header. Correct
Is? So now we will use it. A
Let's copy this. We are going people
Let's use it in the layout for now. So
I'm using the header here. Ok?
This will have to be imported. So import it
Let's take it. It was imported from here. End
If you look at it now, it looks something like this.
Will be visible. Because we paint here every day
The theme is using set CN. So we
It is visible here in this color right now.
Sign in and whatever you want to use.
So now we can make a banner here also.
Yes, quickly. So I quickly coded it.
I also write it because it is simple
html will remain. So I quickly code it.
I'll write it down and then show it to you.
Explore. Ok? So these guys, we have our
Hero banner has also been made. And whom that
I have used Simple Home here.
On the page. Ok? So what's simple inside it?
Is? Look here. So if I make this
Should I refresh? So you can see that
Inside, there's a simple image here and here.
There is text that is animating the image
Is. Ok? What is this simple thing here? One
This is how we have used HTML here.
We have used 'and' here. Here
I will show you. Here we have used
is the framer motion. Ok? New Seat React
For the library icon. Ok? All this
Code Guys I'll put on my gib. There
You can see from it. Normal HTML use in it
Already done. Tailored CSS used
Is. End frame motion is used. Correct
Is? perfect. So we used it here.
Took. And now we have a header like this here
Pay sign in and here we have it like this
This is some of the content. It looks like this right now
Used to be. Ok? perfect. Ok? End
What have we done here?
Have everything you need here in Constant
Static and Hero Slider here 1 2 3
The image has been taken. We have made the image public.
It is placed here in the folder. 1 2 3
Which we are using here.
And then we use it here.
Here we are rotating it.
Ok? perfect. So these guys we did
Gave. And now let us do one thing.
I am closing this. Ok? Ok.
Now let's do one thing. We are logged in here
And we also make a sign up. Ok?
So I make a route here. I say
new folder and inside it I say
because log in and sign up that anyone
can access. So I'm saying here
I am creating a route group. Public. Correct
Is? Or do one thing. Auth says
This. Ok? Auth will remain. And here I am
Inside this I am saying a login end pagex
Ok? This is how we are making logs
In End Page. So this will be our route. Correct
Is? So I will quickly convert this into simple html
I will define it. also of end register
Let me quickly define simple. Correct
Is? Ok? So these guys, we registered
And login using simple HTML.
Made the tail wind and set CN
It has happened. Ok? We have just had a lot more
Nothing has been added to it. So if
Let me show you. So let's come here. So
This is our view of Create Account here
You can see here which is name, email, phone,
password and then he can select that
He is a job seeker or a recruiter. Ok?
And then he will create an account. If
If the user already has an account then click
Here to sign up. The sign will go here
On these. Ok? Again here he name and
Will give email. Name & Email & Password
Will give. And then log in as a what is it?
Is it a recruiter or a job seeker then that sign
These will do it. Ok? So these are our two already
We have created a page here. Ok?
So now let us do one thing with this. Go
First, we are on super base. Ok?
Superb. So let's come here. and log it
Do this from your email. Ok? So I
Here I say sign in and I am here
I will have to log in with Ghub. So one
Let's work. Let's do it quickly. So
We will log in here. Ok?
As soon as you login, you will see in Super Base
what needs to be done? First you have to organize
Will have to make it. Inside the End Organization
You can create your own project. So here
But we say let's give it a name
I say Next JS 16
This is called a job board. Ok? Similarly
We write it down. Ok?
Job and make this bigger too.
Next This is personal. Ok? and then
We say it here. Ok? personal
It is and will remain free. And here we are
This is called creating an organization. So we
People create their own organization here.
Are doing. Ok? Now that it is created
If he goes, he will say here that one of his
Create a project. Create New
project. We give ours here
Give the name of the project
Job
Board. Ok? This is how we give
Are. Ok? Job boards do it
Simple. So this will remain. and then password
Password of the database. So I give it
Anything right now.
Ok? I gave this. I copy this
I will do it. Here we say that we
Create new project. Ok? So, say this
The need has been strong. Ok? So, a job
Let's do job boards.
Ok? So let's copy this. End
Here we call it create new
project. So this is our super base here.
A project will be created. Correct
Is? So look, it has been created here. So
What do we do now? Now we have here
You have to connect this to your necklace. Correct
Is? So if you come down here. So here
But look, we have it visible right now here.
Connect to your project. Ok? So one
Let's work. First, okay, then
We will see to that. Ok? So basically we
What was to be done? We will look into this later.
Ok? So let us connect it first.
Let's take it. And then we will deal with that later.
We will see. So here is the project
URL end you will see our here.
I'll delete this later Guys A. So you
Create your own and then use it.
Ok? So here we create a file.
Is it okay? So, we would have made it here.
There are A here. Ok? So I am saying
New FileNB.
Ok? So I'm saying it here
Super
Base
Project URL. Ok? So Super Bass
The project URL and our key will be. So
I would give it this in the project URL.
Am. And it is ours. So that's already here
But if you look at it, it is also there. So I this
I am telling you about it here also. Ok?
Where did we put the project URL and key?
Did? Our
Defined in the file. Ok? His
After you come here a little bit, then here
Let's do one thing. Let's come here. This
I am closing. Ok? Now we
What is the plan? Let's come here. Connect
We have to do it with nexj. So here you are
Connects to so many applications
You can. So here we say
Connect. So now let's go here to the app
On the framework. And yes, look here
The framework we have to do for Negjust.
Our app is the router. The app is using the router.
Is. And then this then we have this one here
So I added mine to it. Ok? Now
He is telling us that first of all we are here
But we will have to make this. Ok? Utils
superb end server dot es end inside
Client and then these middle ware. Ok?
So let's do one thing.
Let's come here. And here we are here
Let's create a folder Utils. Ok?
Let's make another one inside this one. Superb its
Inside there will be the file client there will be another file
server.ts ok? So what do we have here?
have to do it? When here in the client area
If you come to the client section, you can copy this one.
Do this and paste it here. Correct
Is? So, we have to install this.
Now. So and then copy this to the server
do it. And we have to put this in the server.
Ok? So here we set it up. End
A This is saying that middleware also gives us super
We also need to create middleware within the base.
Have to do it. So here comes the super bass end.
Let's make it middle ware dots. This
I'm copying Pay Again here. again
I am pasting it here.
Ok? So we pasted this also. So
This is my end here. Ok? So
Ours is perfect. Ok? Ok. So one job
We do. Let's install it now.
Ok? So here we say
Let's go to the terminal. And I say
NPM this and this one. Ok? So
Super Base SSR End Server Client Super
Base SSR. Ok? So this is our ad.
Went. So our error also went away. here
There is no error. There is an error with cookies.
No problem. So this is a next public
Super ok, we know what to do here.
Will it have to? A here we have the next public
A super base URL will have to be given. and that
So we have to pay here a next
Public Super Base Public Default Key. So
What will we do to him here? This one
I will give it. Ok? So I did this.
And now how to access it?
It is being said that here you can add your page.js
You will come here to TSX. So you are here at your
Import it like this to Superbuzz
Hookies ko and thon aap apne yahan pe table ko
Select it. Then you can get your date here.
You can. Ok? It is easy. It is very easy.
Ok? So, but now we have connected here.
Have taken it. And now let's see that this
Is everything going perfectly or is there something else going on?
There is no error. And let's look at this, right?
Is it working or not? So here we see
Let's run our app once. So
I think everything is going perfectly. Ok? So this
We don't need headers everywhere. Or
If we need it, we'll see later.
Will remove it. Ok? Now we come here
Are. And we come to our place.
Let us close this. And this
Let's make it a little bigger. oh sorry yes here
Come on. So here we have a table.
Editors here let's go to the table editor.
And here we say new table.
Ok? So we have a new table here.
Let's create it. So now the user table
In a way, first we create the user table.
Let's create it. So what am I here for?
I am saying this
User profile. Ok? User profile.
Ok? And then we have our own here.
It will remain created. Add column does. I
I call this name a name, we say okay
Is? Here we call it an integer.
Gotta text. Ok? We are here at
Let's text this to the name. and then
We have Add an Email
Add
On
Ad here, we say ah here
What will happen? Password
Roll
Profile
We will have the picture and here.
Resume URL and then we will have
The bio here is fine, so this will be and this
What will remain is our text again and
We could have texted this here as well.
Yes, you should have just texted this as well.
You could have texted the password roll as well.
We also have password text.
Right now we just text everyone. Correct
Is? A. Okay. I'm texting for now
Am. We will change it later. Ok?
So I'm saying text this and here
But we will call it text. Ok? So this
I selected it. And this is the email
What will remain of us? unique in a way
Will remain. Correct? So we will come here. And we
I will say this is unique. Email It Means That Her
The email address of a user will be unique.
Ok? So we did this. And here
Let's save this. Ok? So this is our
A table will be created here. than we
What will people do here? RLS Policy
Will add. And if you don't know this
Guys how does Super Bass work?
What is RLS policy? Its Guys
I have made a separate video. Please
Go and see him. Made in detail.
And from that you get complete knowledge of Super Base.
Will go. Here we say add R. So
Look here, this has been created by us.
Table. And here we will say add.
RLS Policy. Ok? So here we are
I will say that if you come here then I will say
Create policy and then we are here now
what are you saying a permission for all okay
So I'm saying all and all here.
What all will we give him now, true, okay?
Yes, and because we have this now,
Okay, so we are making it true.
And here we'll call this save policy.
Okay, so because this is permission for everyone.
So we have added RLS policy here.
Gave. Ok? For this particular table
This is our table that we made. Ok?
So now let's go to the table here. So
If you find a table here, table and table
If you want to see the data, if you want to see the columns then you
Here you can go to the table editor. Correct
Is? Then if you want to see the relation here
Are. So you can go to the database here.
yes. So I'm going to go to the table editor here.
So here you can see this is yours here
Pay table is for user profile. All this
It is his table. Ok? And this is what we people
What do you do now? Turn on dark mode
Let's give it to him. Ok? It would be okay to see
In. And in the same way if you have here
Show the schema and relation in a database
So here you can see that you
In the database you will find here
It will be visualized. Ok? So perfect.
So let's go here to the table editor.
Pay. So now let's do one thing. a I call this
I have been close to others. Ok? And I
Create a folder here on this one here
I am doing it. New folder. I am telling
Type it here. Ok? and inside it
I am filing a new one. Index
Okay, and here's the export.
Interface
User okay so user will be my and its
Inside, we can define it here.
The ID will remain a string and the same way I do.
The name will remain the same, the email will remain the same.
The password will also remain at the pass created.
If it remains in this then it will remain updated and created.
I forgot that there will be an end password as well, so I
I am saying here that if the string roll remains
In the roll we can have here ah
job here here
Recruiters. Ok? So be the recruiters
Can. We hire recruiters, not admins.
We are the people. I am keeping only two right now. Correct
Is? So we have job seekers either
Recruiter can be either of these roles
It is in it. Ok? then here
Profile
Picture. Ok? will remain in the string. So
We will see this now. End
The resume URL string will remain. and then
What was ours? It was bio.
Ok? This will also be a string. So, this
I will have an interface that we created.
And from here we exported. This we
People what is this now? one way type
We created an interface for the script.
If I assign a variable to this
If I give it to any function then this is acceptable.
will do that if a function is returning
So all these things should happen. in that
If someone is using a variable, someone
If you are assigning data, it should be of this type
There must be data. It means that it means this
It happens. Consider it like this for now. Ok?
So what do we do now? So look now
First thing when we register here
If we do this, we will have all these things.
Will not happen. Created at Updated at
Profile Picture Resume URL All of these
It will not be there at that time. So we have some
There will be traditional name, email, password, role.
It will be like this. Correct OK. So now we are
Let's do one thing. Create your own actions
Are. So let me create a folder here.
a new folder
Actions. So here I am saying new
File user dot action. Ok? We are here
I'm creating user actions, right? I'm saying actions.
Let's give it action, okay, so our
Brother, user actions will be dots, this is fine.
what can we say here use server ok
So what are we doing here?
We're creating server actions in a way, so we
Here use server a defined top
Pay okay what do we need to import here
But now you will see here, so here we
I showed you how to use it.
There you will have to import what we have
I have defined this one here.
Which we had defined here, right?
Went? In routers, in clients, in servers
We had defined this in . Ok?
Created CreateClient. Ok? So now
What do we have to do here? So here I am
What will I say on this? So here we will say
Create
Client. Ok? Super Base Server. Ok?
Here we are creating the server action.
So, we have created the client here.
Imported it. Ok? what do we give
do? Our user that we created,
Interface. The user interface we created
A, we will import that also. User A was
User A was this user, you could have imported it.
import user from type index sorry
If the type is empty then this will not happen
Okay, so I've done that, now what do we have to do?
Now suppose a user would need us
If he is giving me the password then I will use the same password.
I will not store the beans in the database.
what needs to be done is it needs to be hashed
For that we use Bcrypt here.
Let's do one thing, terminal
Let me go and here's what I'm saying.
clear npm
IEC PT GS Okay so here we are
Installing Paycrypt GS
Yes, our installation is complete, okay?
Here we import
From Bcrypt Gs so we have this also here
Pay beep o bcrypt a bcrypt hoga na
So here we have adopted BCrypt as well.
Import tax ok perfect what did you do it for
We already know that because
we need to hash the password okay so
Now I say here export com
This is called user register registration.
Let's remove it here. End
This sink will be here here. Ok?
Here the data will come to us. Ok? So
Now we will see what kind of date it is.
He will not come. So here we are
What are you saying? See registration now
Will take. Ok? Let's register it
Simple registration.
So this is our form data, the data will come here.
And this data that will come to us, guys, this
What data did we tell you that this type
We have defined when it will register
So what will the user give us all these things?
He will not give it to us nor will we have his name or email.
If the password is there then the roll will be correct.
What we have to do here is this data
It will come to us, so I will say it here.
It will require some partial data.
Meaning that not all the data, some partial data
All the data will come to us, if I
Should I give it to you? Suppose if I give it to you
So now whatever I will use this, action with this
Inside this I have this type of data
Will have to provide it. Ok? which I
Can't do it for every user at that time.
Correct? Because the ID is updated inside it
Ad created at Suppose that's okay? All this
We don't have some fields there yet.
So what will we do here? what am I
I would call it partial
Whose will it be partial and partial, friend? These
The user we have created. Ok? Now look
Now what will happen is that this partial data is his
It will accept whatever data you give it.
If you want to give, you can give from this, but only this
Of the users, it's okay, which we have
defined okay perfect now we
What will people say? Cost Superb and Create
We would have imported it at the client end.
If cookies are not allowed with the next header then it is ok
We have given this here and superb
We have a client here and this
What will we do here, wait, okay?
So we will put an alert here, our superb
It will come closer, okay, so now let's do one thing.
Let's do it here, here I say
Cost A here in the first step, let's say
What should we do if a user registers?
For that, believe me, what have we done?
email is done, we gave unique so we
You will also check that yes, this is the user.
whether we have it or not if I already have it
what should I do if the user is from that email
I will give him an error from here so this user
Exists so what am I saying here
Look, okay, so what can I say now?
I am superb okay from from user
Select all, select this in the email
data dot email came his end single if
I already got the email so I am here
But what will I do if I get it here?
I will simply throw this away so that the user already
Exist Okay user we got it here
We threw an error, it's fixed now.
Suppose I do one thing here.
I say user
Data
dot
Let's make it greater than 0. Ok? So
This will happen. Now assume that he got it all right.
Gave it. The email is also correct. all of his
Correct. So what do we have to do now? Who
Hashing the password provided by the user
Will have to. So what can we do here simply?
Are you? We use crypto in password.
I am using it. These data dots in the hash
Password and isko salt me ​​10 de de rhe r
He has it. Ok? So what is this for us?
Will he? It will also hash the password. Correct
Is? Data Dot Password. Ok? Look, now give
Look, he is there.
dot password look at all this it question
It is marked that it contains partial
Maybe we already have it defined here
If it has been done then now there is a question mark on everything.
Whereas we have put a question mark somewhere here
It is not given that this is optional.
I could have given the optional here because
I've used partial here, so now
what will I do here dot password end
I have given this hash password to him now.
What we have to do is assume he has the password.
If you have done it then what should we do? Insert
We also have to do what we have with this data.
We have taken the user's. So here I am
what am I doing simple look here here
But I am telling him that he waited super
Base from user insert what to do
data that we have received from
What do we have to do here? Insert
If you want to give it to him, then accept that now something
An error occurs, so here we have done a simple aap kya
You can do this by throwing an error dot message in case of error.
Okay, if there's an error, let us know right away.
Try catch block will also have to be done here
So let's do one thing here first.
People say try this within try
We keep everything, if you suppose an error occurs
If it is inside then close it here
He will have to. Ok? So try and catch
Sorry, we will have a catch here. In the catch
What will we do here simply? a catch
will be. So we didn't do anything wrong
Guys. Ah yes, put this in. So here we are
A throw like this make the registration fail.
And when you assume there is no error then simply
What can you return from here? Simple
Return an object. make a status
Success and message the user here
Register successfully. just the same way beans
You can pay here. And this is what we people
Let's make the status true. And here we are
People in this case
What will we say here? here we
People, please accept this message that is coming.
I will give the same message with this one. So here
But we will give it to him like this. Correct
Is? We will remove this. So this case
What will happen here? Status falls.
So what will happen to me? In a way, the user
Register action. Ok? action
U Register Register Action Yes Okay. So
So look what we just did? One
Here, A is its sink. Ok? So
This is what we did here, create client end
Then we showed it here. saw that
If we already have the user, then we
Here date dot email already given to him
that if there is already a user with this email
It exists. So throw it here.
Make this error. Ok? User Already
Exists with this email can say you are a V
Email because we can treat the same email as a unique
It is made. Ok? saved the password
We assigned a password to the data and
Then we came to Superbas's place. insert
You have submitted your data. Now suppose that insert
Some error occurred while doing it. So here I
But it threw an error. Otherwise, simple
Returned Success True End User
Register successfully.
Simple status false end whatever error in catch
Is. Ok? What do we do now? Us
Let's go to the register page here.
Pay. Ok?
What do we have to do with this? from a bird
Will have to validate. Ok? So one job
We do. You will have to install it first
Us. Let's hit enter. So here we are
Using React Hook Form. Jord
I am using it. end hook form resolver.
Ok? So let us close it.
And here we can use it now.
So what will I do with it here?
Import.
import useFormHook from here this
We just installed all three here.
We imported all three here. Correct
Is? We have to do the same for logging in as well.
Will have to. So I'll do it quickly
Because this is a small thing. hopes
Yes, you must know. Still don't know if
I did this using React Fook Form
It has happened. A special video has also been made of this
Is. You can see that. Ok? So I
What should I say to him here? Name to Z Dot
I will say string because it is of string type.
What will happen? And then whatever you have here
The message is Max, he can provide it.
yes. Ok? So this will be my Z here.
Dot string minimum must be minimum two
Otherwise it will give error. Max be so
Otherwise it will give an error. end rejects
That's why I added a little bit that if
Suppose someone gives a letter or something else
gives off. So this is what we have said that name
Yahan pe name can only contain letters and
Space. Ok? So here in the name
Can only be a space and a letter. useless
There is no number etc. here. Correct
Is? perfect. So we did this to whom?
For? So we did this for the name. This
A little bit below, we will say it here.
This is Z dot email. Ok? End okay? This
This way. So please enter Z dot email
Valid email. Max should be five.
This should be the minimum. Max be so
Needed Ok? So now this email validation
He will do it himself here. In the same way, we
People will say Z dot Z dot. Ok? So this
What will remain of me here? The one with F. Ok?
So what did I give here? Minimize this
10 should be the maximum. Add Rajks
Gave. Please enter valid F number. it means
That a little bit of validation was also added. F
Same for the number. Ok? So a little bit here
Let's do this. Now for passwords too
Let us add a little bit. Z Dot
String. Ok? So this will be mine
Whose? Ah, this will be mine, yes, this will be mine
for the password. Ok? So here we have
First, add the minimum and maximum passwords.
For that there can be a minimum age. Maximum
This much can happen. Ok? In registration
Must be A to Z. There should be a capital
It should be small, there should be a number. End
Whatever you get from that, you can download this ad here.
You can do what you want to do. Ok? Meaning
They would have removed it for a special character.
Are. And then in the same way for us to roll.
So what will we do here? Now look
There can be two types of rolls. Correct
Job Seeker & Recruiter. So here we are
What to do? h dot reward. Ok? reward
It is in this. Ok? and in the same way
see here job dot ah this is job
Seeker and Recruiter. Ok? Im and Ye
It will remain mine. Ok? So okay? I did this
Gave. And okay, we're done here.
Is. So we will have to create a schema for this. So
Let's do one thing. I am removing this
From here. So I'm saying cost and z
The dot object will remain. Inside this is my
The entire schema will remain. And here we are
What will people do with this? Close and close.
So this is my schema. This is what we have schema
It is made. Ok? Now the schema we
People will use it. How will you use it? See
Let us first type it. Type
register
Form data and here we are here
Kind of okay z dot info type of user
Register Schema Its this type of schema
We have defined it here.
Its type is okay cost here we have
Register: Yes, it will be the perfect same.
okay so what did we do here
Register Handle Submit We are here now
We will make it so let's do one thing, let's do this also
We will see and then we will form a state
In the form state we will get this error
Use form we used hook which we
Imported from here
And we will tell him this type of
Will remain. And in resolver resolver we have
passed this Jord Resolver which we have
It was imported from here. Ok? Now
Jord Resolver will have to tell us
Schema his. So we already have the schema here
This is defined on it. So here
We passed the same schema to it. Correct
Is? So now with its help we can do our
There is a form, you can tell me that. Register Tax
We can do this in our field. Ok? End
We call this submit.
Let's call it a submit handler. And we
I used this here, somewhere else in the form
In.
So here
We have the form here in the form
You used it, right? So we have it here
Let's use it. Ok? So this is what we used
Done it. We will see how this looks now.
We have to do it from. I am removing this.
Ok? perfect. So it came to us.
register. So how do you register first? So
Look how simple this is already. what did we
Did? Schema defined. type created
Because we will have to tell it the type. Use
form hook because we type
Using the script. Type here
We took it out. And then we here
But did you use this? Your use form
The book that we have installed here
Did react book form. Ok? End
Then what did we do here? He has a here
I told you about it. And then resolver has its own
Passed the schema. It will give three things
To you. Register, Handle, Submit and Then You
Error. So you can use this. register
Why? that I just registered my field
I will do it. How will I do it? Look, he will come here.
We will have this input. So here yes
This will be here is the input. So here I am
What should I do? here for now here
I will call this this sorry this register
Hai register dot name. So it means that I
I am telling you that this is registered in the name field.
I am doing it with the name ones. Ok? and now
What will we do here? value it
And we will remove it like this. Correct
Is? So that's how we do it here.
Will come here.
What do we have here? Email this
Will remove it.
Will come here in the same way. Here at our
The phone is nearby.
It's our phone. We will remove this. in the same way
My password is here. So here
Will come. My password will appear here.
We will remove this. And similarly, mine is here.
Will it come to me? Our radio is here.
We do one thing here for this.
When the change happens, then here we will be together.
Let's take the state, basically it is better.
Will remain. So here I am saying cost
Role and this is how my role will be. So
What should I say to this here? Roll Set
This is called set role. Ok? set
This is called a roll. And then we are here
What will you do? So where did this thing of mine go?
These? A roll group here it is. Ok? So I
I am saying here that we end this
Will remove it. So what do I come here for?
roll it
Roll
Value as a job sticker and job recruiter.
Ok? So a roll a value. Ok? So one
Let's do the work simply, I value it.
I will pass it. I will pass the value
I think it will be perfect because we
already there okay okay ah okay this
We accept it because what does it say?
is assign string assign type this
This this recruitment yes ah yes is perfect
Okay, so kind of tell us how to type this.
It means that we are telling him that
It can be either a job seeker or a recruiter.
This could be only one of two things.
This is fine, so we have defined it here.
Done whenever the on value changes it
I mean, we can find radio here.
Will go get that this ah a roll mill
Will go. Ok? So form data we now
I am not going to use it. So we make this
We will see. I will remove it later. Ok?
perfect. And we come here. Now
Look, when the user is here. so it
Meaning that here the user can be considered registered.
Let's go. So when the user is on the register
So the user can also make changes there. If
Guess he felt it all and
This changed it. So I'll watch it
I want to know what he changed. It
I mean, because it's important
For us. So I'm going to put it here in a way
I want to check it every time. So I this
I can put a pay watch on it. How to put on a watch
Am? What we have here, here we
I will say who
Roll End
I will watch the role. Ok? To the roll.
Ok? I will watch the role. So it
Meaning that whenever there is a change, this will happen.
The value will be updated with us. Ok?
Now look, we don't need to take a state.
Is. I will watch this with this and change it.
I can see. what value update in this
Happened? What changes have happened? Ok? And here
We also provide default values.
Can. Which is whatever I have here.
So what values ​​do we have here?
Is? We would have blanked out the name.
Are. We give this in the same way.
By default we do jobs.
If you have to give whatever you want, according to
You can see. Ok?
And we can also set its mode here.
You can know which type of work and when. So
I'm saying here mode A and mode I
I am saying that it should run on blur or on blur.
Whenever there is blur, this should work. and its data
Update and check validation. Correct
Is? So this is what I am saying. And now I
What do we have here now? Handle
Submit handle. Ok? So what should I give this a
I work. a handle change it
We don't need it. Ok? So I this
I am removing it because we already have it.
Data will be available whenever we have changes
will be. Ok? So I am removing this. it
We don't have to use it. So I am saying
cost on
Submit. Ok? So I'm saying cost.
On submit. Now watch on Submit What It Means
What type of data will it be? This is what we
This type of data is defined here
will be. Ok? This type of data will be there. So
I have already typed this here, that is why I
I took it out from there. So on submit and
Now we can do our work here.
Whatever has to be done. Man lo it means that try
Kiya can do it in the block today. Now sleep one
Let's work. Here we are one here
cost
Let's load this set. Yes, set
The loading fails. So whenever I
If it clicks, what should I put it here?
Will I do it? I will make it true. It means that whenever
There will be a click and whenever this click changes
So I will make it true. it means that at that time
We can disable the button. Loading
You can show me whatever you want to do. Ok? End
Then I can try saying it here.
And then we are here to catch and then our
You can write whatever code you want. End
You can also do finaly and finally. finally
Let's tell him. And finally, my
What can be done? by failing the loading
Can. Ok? So this is how we did it
Did. And then what will we do now? it
I will use our handle which is submitted.
Where will I do it? This is our jo
The form will be here, we will have the form here.
So
Form on submit. This is my handle submit. End
What do we have inside it? On submit. A
Submit is this one. clear? So I did this
Gave. And I think now is perfect. A if
If we come here, what is coming?
We got Watch F OK this import which
This should not have happened from here to here.
wala fi is okay ah yes this one is okay
So ok sorry, we will remove this also.
People, what do we have to do here now?
This watch that we got here, we watch it here.
We are using this, copy it here.
Will we be able to find ourselves from here?
Here we will find this watch, okay?
The watcher will keep watching this and value it.
You will get the update and let's do one thing
And ah, this is what we have taken.
Let's remove this. Ok? to the set value
A set roll to. So I am removing it.
Ok? So I am removing it. And I
Simple, I am taking it here and setting the value.
And I am using it. instead
That I should take a separate statement instead.
I will use it here. And here
But this is the set that we used.
I use this to set the value in the role.
I will take it. And I Think Now to Be Perfect
Needed Let's use this. Yes.
Role Role Value as Job Seeker and Job
Recruiter. So this is our perfect one.
Satisfied this is JavaScript which is yes ok
Is? Then it will be ours. Ok? Now we
People should come here and refresh it.
Let us see if there is any error anywhere.
Perfect submit so look at this if I
I can fill it with anything here. Ok? End
If I fill it with anything here, it
It will tell you to please enter this. a job
We do. So let's come here.
Here we might have an error here. So
Here we are like this is the full name, right?
Suppose there is an error here, then we
How to show the error here? So I am a
I work here and I say if
Suppose I have an error already, we have
Hai error dot name. Ok? so error dot name
If it is already there then the error we have seen here
I have already taken out this one, this one, this one
Wala to errors dot name. So if inside it
Suppose there is an error in the name, then we have
It will come here. So what am I here for?
Will I do it? here pe mo sorry here pe me
I will say this
motion.p and here inside it here
error dot name dot message whatever the message is error
Show me that. And here is the class, yes, this
correct class name text sm end margin
We gave this. And this is perfect. End
We call it then initial. End
I'll say it here in the initials.
Let's set the opacity to zero. and animate a
And we also call it here in y
Let's give it -10, okay? And then when animated
It will happen so let's do one thing. a little below
Let's do this.
And when it comes here in animation,
What will I do with it? Make Y zero
Give. Ok? So this is perfect. like this
With this we can make our own everywhere. error
I will copy this. and in the same way
Here I will do this for email.
If the email is
There is email. Sorry Email Email Email Yes Email
And similarly here we have the password.
will be.
Password here. same way here
We have the password. So here I am
I will tell you the password.
And in the same way, here also we have the password
I will do it. Ok? So whichever has an error
That message will be visible here. have a password
Went. I became a job seeker. come here
We have. Similarly, yes radio here
There is a group. Here we have motion
It will come here. So if we have here
The role is in the payroll, right? Roll and here
I will pay the roll. So whatever error there is
It will be visible on it. So let's come here.
Let's refresh it. And now I
Think is perfect. If I submit
This is if I press enter here. Correct
Is? 1 2 3 so look at this name contain only
These letters also have to be entered. If I remove
If I give it then it has to happen like this here. See
How is that error coming like this.
It became animated. So this is how you do things
You can animate here and create
yes. Ok? So I'm just refreshing it
Am. And I think now is perfect. Correct
Is? Our recruiter and this fana to this now
Ours is perfect. and likewise
We will also have to do this for A login. So
Let's take a quick look at that. Before that we
People do one thing. So here when he
If he submits then we will do one thing.
Quickly here, here. So here I am
What will I do with it? Cost Rest Is Equal To
Await Register
A, what action did we create here? So
This is our action. So what am I here for?
Will I do it? I will use this action for it.
What will I do with this? I will import it.
And what data will I provide to it?
I will provide this data. And say this
Let us make this question.
So what is he saying now? Yes. Ok. So
What is he saying Guys? a name string
Phone this this this this this. So it is saying
Job seekers. Okay, we missed SS somewhere.
Done it guys. Ok, let's do this. S
It will remain everywhere. So job seekers recruiters.
Ok? Sorry S. So this I think now job
There will be seekers and recruiters. So here
what we used
A Job Seekers and Recruiters Job Seekers
And recruiters and this is what we created here.
Yes, this is perfect. Ok? So that's why
It was giving error. Now I think this
Satisfied as you can see. A
I am satisfied, the guys are correct. A yes. So
Here we have it. Ok? to this
They just remove it. its own ok so be it
Went. And we did it. And here
I'll get a response if I say race.
Dot success a yes status if true
What should I do? So you are here
You can show a twist or anything.
yes. Or what can you do from here? So
Suppose to show register success to stick
So let's do one thing, first a plugin
If you install a plugin, go here.
Let's come here and write XGS toast
So here, okay, let's take the first one.
So let's copy this and come here.
Let's go to the terminal here, we'll do this
Let's install TasteFi Perfect
Done install and come here. So
We will have it here. Ok? So one
Let's work. Let's copy this. and a
Let's come here. We have the layout. A
Let's move on to the layout. paste it here
We do it. What will we need? Toast
Container. And toast container we have here
Pay, let's call it quits for now. Ok?
Simple. Let's see. If this doesn't work then
We will have to call there. Now we the people
Let's come here. A This was ours. So here
But let us copy this again.
And come here. Here we are, this
Let's paste it. a paste it here
We give.
We don't need this. We need this
Is. So what will we do here? As
We will have the success status as true. So
Here at Toast Dot Success and Response
dot message and here we have also
Let's comment. We will see this later.
Ok? And here's what we did.
Is? A from users. Ok? We have here
What is the name of the table, Guys? user
We have a Pro user profile. So the user
Underscore profile autocomplete
No guys sometimes create problems. So this
We will have a user profile and now if we
People will see that we are walking in the right direction.
Needed So let's do one thing. We are one
Let's refresh it once. And here
We enter our name. I say
I am Tarun Kumar and
Here we enter the email. Here
Pay dummy number anything end I say. Correct
Is? Entered it. And now you are a job seeker
Whatever the recruiter wants to do, I am the job seeker.
I will let you keep it. And I say here
Let's do one thing. Works on the network as well
Are. We will also see there that if we have
Whatever is coming, success or failure, it is coming to us.
It will be visible there also. So I say
Create and look here API call made
We have and here, here, look at the user.
Register successfully then our user here
It's registered. So if this user registers
So we have it here in the database.
It should also be visible on the So if I make this
If I refresh, here we have a
There must be data, look, it's here.
But. So guys, this is how we are here.
What are you able to do? your users to your
Register in the Super Base database
Have been. Ok? perfect. So this is our
His work is done. Ok? Now what do we
Have to do it? Login also needs to be worked on. So
I do one thing. I to this, yes to this
I remove the close. All this. Ok? These
We remove everything. And we have
There is no login page here. So in this
We'll have to use this chord first.
Guys. All this that we have like schema etc.
It is made. So I'm copying this
I am right now. And one more thing here that we have
Loading is taken. So from this here
We have given this, look at this one. Ah
Create account here
What can I say? So here if ah
If loading remains true then what should I do here?
Will I do it? Ah here simple creating
Account Else Create Account. Ok? So this
So if loading is true then I will
Here I will show you how to create an account.
It means that the text changes in the button itself.
Will go. The text in Else will remain the same.
Ok? So we did this too. And I
Think this one is perfect. Now we are here
What do you do? Our ego, this is our ego
It is the login one. So let's do one thing. This
We can copy the schema here.
Are. They copy this too. everything
Let's copy it. Ok? here I am
I am copying. I am going to login.
And here we will remove it.
Ok? We don't have to use this form.
To the data guy. Because we are here
I am using Jord. So why should we
I have to use it. And we have it here
I will copy it from.
We will paste it here.
And what rules do we need here?
should would? You will need a password. no phone
We need it. Phone at the time of login
What would be needed? I don't even need a name
will be. Ok?
So we will need this at the time of login.
Three things. Ok?
And we call it user.
Login schema.
Ok? The user will be logged in.
Here also, here also. Ok?
And we remove the name from here. Phone
Let's remove the . It's perfect. And this too
We will see. We will definitely remove this. Correct
Is? We don't need this. End on Change Key
We don't need it either. So that's us too
Will remove it. So we don't even need a watch.
Is. Where do we need the set value?
Will it be necessary? Whatever we have here will be ours.
No, this button group will be this. So here
But what will we do? Simple
Roll
Value okay so here value as a
here pay log info data dot roll a if
I took it, yes, okay, then it will be like this, okay
If yes, then according to what you can give, so we
What we've done here is basically
Direct type defined there
static, you already tell its type here
You can do it simply here, which we have here
I had given this to you, see, according to you
As you like it, the way you like it
You can do whatever feels right. Ok? Ez Ye
isn't it here you can see this one
This is also perfect. This is also satisfied
For this. Don't you have it? Not logged in.
Register here. Ok?
Register form data and perfect hai ye. So
This is ours. And we have value pay
There is nothing required for change in this. beans
We don't even need a name here. Here
But name may not be required here also. And this
So ours is already perfect. here
What will happen to us? Handle Submit Already
We have. So handle submit will be this. End
What do we need to do to handle submit?
Let's do an on const here
On submit. Ok? On Submit Pay On Submit
We will have to provide it. So one
Let's work. Come here when on
The handle will be submitted. So this handle which you submit
Who is this? This is his. Ok? A and Also
We will see auto complete here later.
If I want to turn it off then this is ours
Handle Submit Where is this coming from?
Where do you get this use form hook from?
Alright and this one from React Hook Form
We will now create a new action in this.
And then we will use that for login, okay
Now we have to register the field.
We already have this register.
This is what we get and I get it here.
What do you have to do? First, send an email here.
So what do we have to do here?
End email. Ok? So this will be our one
Email Second Password This will be the password. Correct
Is? The end password is both. And here
We have already set the value here.
from its set value. Ok? So this is what we
Did it. And I think it's perfect. M Error
We will have to do it for this also. So this is a job
We do. Let's copy this here
Than this one. So let's come here. here
Where did you go? Here it is. So what are we here for?
will do their
What will we do with him here? What
Do we have it? Email. That means email here too
We will have it. then be here
What will happen to us? Password. So password.
Password. And it will happen here too
Password. is it done. What about us after that?
Is? Here we will have it here
This is the radio group, right? Of the radio group.
I take it here and sorry
It is not copied completely, yes, it is okay.
what will happen here and here now roll
If there is an error in the roll then roll here
He will go and whatever his message is will be visible.
If it goes then we have done this also and I think
Now is perfect and let's do one thing here
But we would have taken another loading.
Ok?
const loading set loading false end now
What can we do here on our submission?
Can you? TRAI
Here, there will be a catch and error in the final
Finally. Ok? So here it would be like
I will set loading to true here.
Ok? And here finally fall kar
I give. Now let us write our code here.
Is. What do we have to do before that?
Its action will have to be defined. So here
Come on.
Here we have export cost
User login so we will have this. Correct
Is? So right now, let's do one thing here.
Are. The beans themselves tell this. it means
That is partial from this. So from this
What will come to us from here, log in
Email, password and password will be sent at the time of login.
Roll and we have here because partial
It has been used. So therefore out of this
Will find partial. If I look here
Na so if you do data dot here. So
As I showed you earlier
Data dot to you here on all
A question mark will appear because what is this now?
Understanding that we need partial values
You will get something from it. You won't get everything. It
Meaning that you won't get everything. If I were here
Should I remove the partial and give you this simple one?
Now if you look, I do it here.
Dot. Now look, where do you see the question mark?
Will not be visible. It means that now he is saying
That all values ​​are accepted in it. It
Meaning that if you put this data here in a
You will give the object and all this data inside it
You will not stay. All this data is for you
Errors will be seen. So here we
Did you use it? Partial. Ok? Here
But we used partial. it means that
Some data will remain from it. perfect.
Let's remove it.
And what did we do here? A Super Pace
We have connected it. Ok? Now we
What will people do here? Now suppose that
What do we have here for the user?
Will you come? Will you come to us here? This
Let's remove it. Let's remove this as well now. Our
You will get email, password and role here.
Now suppose a user tries to login
He tries. And that email is yours
It is not in the database. So what will you do?
You? You will tell him that brother, this is just an email.
It is not there or it is just a password.
Not there. Then you will do something like this. Ok? So
What do I say here? cost is user
Exist. So I'll find it here again.
I am taking it and throwing it away.
The error here is simple. Went to my table.
Found them all. Email, which is this data
The email arrived. Yahan pe single ko agar here
If I got it on pay, I didn't get it. So here I am
What am I doing? No User Found With This
Email. I am telling you one thing that this user
From here any user can contact us through this email.
Not there. Ok? perfect. what do we have now
Do you want to do it here? Now watch when the user logs in
If he does, we will also give him a token here.
Will have to give. json web token jw
Tea. So let us do one thing. him this
Let's install it quickly. already
Here we come first and then I
I say here clear and npm
json web token and install
This has been added here and here we are
What will people do import from json web
We have done the token from here and I am here
Well, let's assume that this is correct.
Email: Now we should check our password also.
If so, what am I doing here?
I am checking the password, it is fine like this
Basically what we did here is brpot
Use the compare function to find the password.
Dia and Iz User Exist Already Our
Will come closer. The password we stored
I will compare both of them here.
This will tell whether it is correct or not. Correct
Is? Now suppose it is not correct then here we
Pay told invalid password. Ok? But
There is a catch here. Ok? So here you are
What can you do? See if you
Specific information will indicate that your email address is incorrect.
Is. Your password is incorrect. So that user
Will he understand that yes, this is an email. Value
If someone tries to hack it,
What will make you think that a good email is?
Not there. password, okay, this means email
Correct. There is no password. I mean good ma'am
Entered wrong password, entered correct but email is correct
Not there. He will understand it this way. So what are you
Can you do it? You are here simply
Do more here here. If either of the two
There is no one here, so you are simple
invalid please enter
Valid credentials ok like this please
Enter valid credentials as specified to you
Why don't you have to send a message to the user?
If you don't give it, then that thing is not right.
So we have done this here, okay now.
Let us create a token here also.
What will we have to do to create a token?
Cost token is = JWT and here
We will take the default secret key and
We created a token here. Use of JWT
Did. We put a dot sign here. We
The user who already exists with us.
The ID will appear here. His email will come. These
We gave in to it. From this data, one
Token will be signed. We need this in our ENV
You will also have to keep your secret that whatever
You can keep whatever you want to keep. in default
Whatever you want to keep. When does it end?
So let me say this for now. Two
Will expire in 2020. Ok? End
Let me copy this over here. And here
Pay comes to your ENB. And I'm okay
Sorry, what can we say here? I
Here I say JWT Secret
and Next JS 16
And 1 2 3 4 keep yours like this
JWT Secret. Ok? So this is what we
Kept it. And here, okay? A, this we
Place it here, our token has been generated.
Now if this token is generated then we have to give it to the user
You will have to give it too. So what am I here for?
Will I do it? Return
I will return it. And I will tell you the status here
I will say he will cry. And then we are here
What will you pass? message whatever message
do you have
Login
Successful login says success. End
Token here. Ok? These three of us here
Pay a message will return from here. Correct
Is? Returning an object in a way
Are. When everything is in our try here
Everything is going well. Well then? Now suppose that
Let's bring this here, this is another one of ours.
The close will be perfect here. will come here
Catch block. So in the catch block we simply
What to do? Catch any error that comes here
And what will we do here? Return
And here we will make the status false.
End
Message message. Ok? So the message that came
Gave it. And let's do one thing. What is this
Am I saying that? to tell him to type
If he is talking about it then we will take care of it.
Ok? And what do we do here?
Are? In plus
And let's also get it gated. Ok?
Whatever message is coming, we are sending it.
Sorry here, ok ok not here
This is okay. I think I will do it right now
Am. Even if I give a new one, the error will still occur.
I will tell you. But okay, okay. disappear from here
Went. So here we have created our action.
Took. User is logged in action. Ok? So
We call this a closet. come here
Are. And what will we do here?
cost
And I would say rest is equal to a wait
And this will be our action. copying this
Are. You will have to import it here.
Ok? And we pass this data to it.
Will give. So this data will be passed. Now I am here
I will check on it. If rest dot status. What
Does it have a status? what if it is true
Will you do it here? Toast
We will have to import toast. So here
But let's come to us here and import it.
Let's have some quick toast.
Toast from Toastify Yes React
Tastify will come here. So here we are
What will people do?
Dot success and rest dot message here.
Ok? We showed the message. Ok?
Else
toast dot error end
Whatever the message is here
I tell him login failed.
and then plus concatenate whatever message
Is. Ok? And when it logs in, it will give a
Let's work and install a library.
We do. Firstly a package so I am here
I come to the terminal and I say
clear this
And I say npm i js cookie
This is called this. Ok? and install it
Let's take it for a cookie. And I think it
You will also have to install the type. so basically
Here we would have imported it first.
Are. import cookie from
JS cookie. Ok? And this will tell us that
He wants this type. So, this too
Let's install it quickly. install this
Done. Ok? Are. It's perfect. So now
What do we do here? This is what we
When we login here, then here
But let's come down a little bit. Yes. Ok?
What will we do here? Cookie Dot Set
I will do it. What to do? Pay token end here
We will have rest dot token a token.
Ok? And that's how we are here
What to do? Roll and here we go
do? This data dot roll is also
People are setting it in cookies right now. Correct
Is? And it's looking for type. So basically
We can do one thing. Simple Cost
Token End
Let's make it a string. And if we
People are now watching. Let's see what
He speaks. Yes. Ok? So understand this basically
That's why he was not her type. so this is
happens in typescript when you type
If you make anything in the script, it
Finds the exact type. of the same type
He should get the data. Otherwise, that error
Starts giving. Ok? So here we have
Now we will tell you why the rules are set.
Already done. But we just set up the token.
Lia in her two piece. Ok? And here
But what do we do? Simple Catch
I am returning from here
Here at Pay to Dot Error and Error we have
Log in
Pay and
error dot
Sorry Message
Ok. So we have to give it an end type.
Will have to. So let's do one thing.
I did this. And here we have our error here.
Also defined. Ok?
So this one which is loading
Let's come here.
We had this sign in here.
Yes.
Ok? And what can I say here?
This? Sorry Else in Signing In and Else
What are we going to do here, which is
Sign in will be visible here, simple like this
If it is okay then we can also use loading
Ours is perfect, okay and now we
People see what we have used it for here.
Did
A show login action is our yes perfect
Okay, so let's come here and give it a try.
Let's refresh and see if everything is okay.
So we have registered a user, correct?
Look here from this email. So I this
I'll copy it now. And come here.
I call it sign in here.
Let's go. And we came here. So I
I am refreshing. There is no error
In it now. So here I am sending this email
We had taken it, I entered it. End
Here we enter the password. I
I say I'll give you anything right now, dummy.
Password. And first let's check this
Is the email one working or not? I am here
I enter any email that our
Not in the database. Ok? I say
I am signed in and it says password ok
We have also added a password field here.
is end validation so here it says sign
It's saying and give us some error.
should login fail read property o i think
Something went wrong reading password so I
I think we missed something, so they would have noticed.
Let's come here reading passwords
Yes and here okay so we say here
are super ok let's do one thing
May be single because they put a limit.
Ok? Let's limit it to one. It
Meaning that if more than one email, let's say
If there is data then it will cause problem at that time.
First of all we will have to solve this. End
Then what will we do here? Is
User Acist? What is he saying? This one
Let's work.
A ok ok let's do one thing. May Be Single
We do it. Ok? So it is better that
Type this here, he will understand it automatically.
Ok? And we have to do one more thing.
here first
Here first of all, here we give it a
Let's work. Same error both the times
We will do it. So it will be much better.
Ok? A Please enter. Yes. Ok? Yes.
Same for email and same for both passwords
The same error will remain. Ok?
I think now is perfect. So I think
It should run perfectly. So let's take a look
Refresh it once.
So let's take a look at it here.
Let's keep this email in email here. End
I'll give you any password here.
For now. Ok? who do 1 2 3
That we don't have email there.
Ok? And now if we look here
Are there any errors in the network?
So it is not. Let's go into the network
And I'm calling it signing here.
Let's see what Abhi says in here.
hai yeh login failed with invalid yes look
Invalid credentials have come up, so because
We don't have that email right now. I am not
I want him to tell me something specific.
whether the email is correct or the password is incorrect
or the email is incorrect. Ok? So now here
We put it correctly. Let's see that
I don't remember my password, friend. See
Let's take what is there. But I'm signing in
Am. Am. The email is correct. I sign in
I have been. And here login is successful.
Went. Ok? So if our login is successful
So what did we do, guys? here
When our login is successful then we
Here the token was set in cookies. So
If we come here to the application,
If we come to cookies, we will get both roll and token.
Guys are available to watch. which is our
Here login again has been successful. Correct
Is? That's what it means. Ok? Because
Our cookies and rolls are both set.
In your cookies. Ok? Browser cookies
In. So our login here is also perfect.
I started walking. Ok? Now guys here when
What should we do if the user logs in?
Will it have to? Suppose the user selected the rule
I did a job seeker recruiter so he
Sending to a different page via a different route
Will have to. So how will you do that? So first of all
Let's do one thing. I did a route here
A group was formed. Let's make another one. I
I say here, oh here it is called private
He has it. Ok? Private. Ok? So
Here we created a route group here
In private name. Ok? create a folder
Are. I make it inside here. I
I say another one in the name of job seekers
Let's create a folder. Inside this, I am here
I will say
We have created two folders in the name of recruiters.
Make. Inside this I will click on New File here.
I do. And I say here
Dashboard end page dots. Ok? and that
Similarly, let us create a file here also.
People Dashboard End page.tsx This is the dashboard
No?
Dashboard Pagex Okay so here we have
But basically a separate dashboard for job seekers
And here we have recruiters for
There is a separate dashboard. So I say here
cost a
Job
Job Seekers Dashboard And Again We're Here
What will you say on this? Return
And in return we are here
What will you do? H2 for now
Job Seekers
Let's make it a dashboard. Ok? This
Let's copy. paste it here
Are. Oh sorry, I will have to export it.
The default end is export it.
Let's come here. Let's paste it here.
What will happen to us here? Job Seekers
Of
Why did it become a dud here? back to this
here
R C R U Y T S
This will become the recruiters dashboard.
Recruiters dashboard is called here
Recruiters
Let's call it dashboard. Ok? So this
We have created job seekers end here
Two different routes of recruiters. From one side
This will be a private route. End for now
I would also create my own layout here.
Am. New File
Make layouts. Ok? So now again
We can create multiple layouts here.
Are. Can create nested layouts. So Again
I hope you know. Ok?
So what will the code be like in it, you can keep it simple
yes. Ok? Like I'm copying this
Am. And I am putting it here as well.
Because I don't see all this inside me.
should would. So you simply stay here for now.
Keep the Pay Div. And inside this our children
Get it rendered. And tell him this. This is it
What about me? A private
Private layout like this. Ok? Now
What could be the benefit here? Advantage ahead
I will show you. Ok? So for now
Let us close this. So we
I have just made a route here and my
These. Now suppose when the user comes here then
He will log in. When there is success
It will come here. And his cookies are ours
It will be set here. So what am I
Will I do it? We would make one here, one here.
Are. Pay cost here
End use router from next navigation.
And we call this route a router.
And what can we do here?
When the router comes, how to push it on whom?
Will you do it? It means that he selected the rule
The obstacles he selected
Recruiters. How can we do it in both cases?
Are? So look here, let's do one thing.
Post a path ah let's do one thing. Ah
This is called URL. And I am here
What do I do? I take a back tick. End
What will I do inside it? This data which
There is a dot roll, I will keep it there. This is the same
Isn't it? Job Seekers & Recruiters. so this is
He will come to us here. end slash
Dashboard Go to its dashboard. And this
Here is my router dot here what is our
The URL with dot push and this. Ok? So
Now if we log in here,
Where will we go? Here. Ok?
Again. So let us see now. A here
Let's come. So now you know the problem with this.
He must have already gone. If you would know
What is the problem in this? So if I'm here
Come and I'll try to log in.
I will send you this email and I will say
And I say here like job seekers
Or recruiters, whichever one you want to go to. So
I am also saying here that job seekers and
Sign in. So where will I go? Now!
Look As soon as it signs in here
It was successful. And we are nowhere right now
Have you gone? Job seekers are here
On the dashboard. Ok? So here we are
We will run on Job Seekers because we have Job
Only Seekers were selected. Correct? Here
But we have arrived at his dashboard. So it
Means everything is going perfectly guys.
Ok? So what would we do here?
Are? This was our layout.
This layout was a private layout.
So here I say class
Container. Ok? Basically in which centre
Where is he? Look, what would be the problem with that?
I will show you now. So basically we have to auto
have to do it. So I'll write it here
Simple Recruiters And when I hit enter
So where will I go? Recruiters
On the dashboard. it means that ah yes look here
Recruiter Dashboard. So this is not right
I should go there directly. So
What do we have to do here? check
Will have to. How can I apply for a cheque? That's us
We will see further. But this error is like this
There is a problem. We have to remember this. Correct
Is? So basically, our problem right now
What we had to do was solve our problem first.
It was that when we logged in, we
When there are recruiters, go there.
If we go to the recruiter here
If someone is a job seeker then he can go to the job seeker route.
Go to So this is what we achieved here.
Done it. Ok? perfect. We did this
Took. Now what we have to do is that when I
When I am logging in, I need to know the login user
Data is needed. So how will you take it? So here
We have already created a user action.
Ok? I have created two actions here.
So here I say export cost
Gate
User data and again async data will remain
And sorry will remain async. And I am here
I say it this way. Ok? So we
Data has to be gated. So how do we get it
Can you? We already have super here.
Is a client of. We will try to catch
Here.
Try and catch us here
Whatever error occurs in the catch, it will be taken here.
Then it's okay here, if the catch happens then it's ours
We got super bass here so we
what will you do here superb dot from that
Let's do one thing first, so here we are
People first come here and wait.
Cookie OK where Next headers OK
I'm taking a cookie from here, wait.
who is taking it out
Token and Equi data do this
Ok
Dot Gate, what name did we give there?
We will get the token and here
But here we will get the dot value so one
Let's work, I would say it simply here.
am dot value okay value in us
You will get the token here, okay now accept it.
that I say here if a not
Not Token
Then what will we do here? throw
New Error
No Token
Found. Ok? It says no token found
If we don't get the token. Ok?
cost
What will we do now? The one who gives the token
How can we verify that? So
ZT Dot can verify it. So here
But what do we have to do? Firstly
We already have import. So here I am
I say this data is user data. So I
What will I say to this? JWT dot verify now
The token will come from there and we will verify it from here.
Can do. How do we have these tokens?
Here this token and what else do we have
You will have to give it here JWT
The secret is your process here.
ENB dot what we had we already here
I had kept it in ENB. So I say
ENB Here we kept the JWT secret. So
You have to give it here, whatever you have
is putting. Ok? So here I have it
Gave user data and processes b saying ok
Let's do one thing like this
Let us assume that it will remain, it means that
It will remain available, so we have collected this user data.
will come to us okay and if I
I'll say if not user if user data and a
Let's do the work and tie a knot, a simple knot
Let's put and not to user data dot
Email if you don't get any of this.
Again Pro New Error in What I Say
Invalid token. Suppose in this case, if my
If the token that I have is verified
It doesn't happen that way, he has an error here.
I will give it again. Ok?
Let's do it this way now.
So again I will give error. So this is perfect
It is ours. Ok? And now again here
We already did it here, right?
Somewhere. Yes, this superb cost a race is
Equal to a wet superb
dot from user profile dot select it
Means that everyone has to select the star dot
Equal end here what we have to do is email
The end of the name field has to be provided here
We will have email user data on this.
Email Guys, we already set it up.
I will show it here in the token. Look at this
We have set up our ID and email address here.
So what we did here is the same as here
We decoded and took out that email. same
What I did with the email was to keep my database
I took that data out of it. here
Will come to us. Quiet, this date, this table
I went. And from this email we have the data
Here we filtered it out. One
Understand this kind of query. So super bass
We can collect data from a particular email.
If we want to remove it, we can do it like this
Can be removed. Ok? perfect. So
We will get a response if I suppose
I would say rest dot error and this rest dot
Data dot length if I have equal end
If it is equal to zero then what am I here
Will I do it? throw new error and what should I do
Will I tell this? User not found.
Ok? So this is it. And suppose that all
What will you do if something goes right? here
We have all the objects
Will go. And what will be there in it? This
In response we will have our
All user data, email, password, phone number etc.
Some. And what are we all doing here?
Will you give? Will return it to the user. whoever
Anyone will make this request. So what is this
Correct? No. So what will we do?
What's not right about that? that we the people
You cannot give your password to anyone. So we the people
What to do? We will remove the password from here.
How to remove it? Look, I'm saying it here
I am a cost user and what am I doing with it?
I am the rest of the response dot data of zero
Okay, we'll get it at zero first.
Item and then what will we do here
user user dot password and I here
What should I say to this, delete it means that I
Password field Password field
If I am deleting it from the object then this
So we can use this normal JavaScript
If I do it then we do the same thing
I gave it here and now what will I do in return?
Just make the status true. End User
Here we are going to use this user of ours.
The user sends it. So it became ours
Guys perfect. Ok? end throw new error
Do it from here. Make an error from here. Something
Vent Wrong.
We did something wrong. When the catch
I will come. So this is our gate of user data.
I am ready. Ok? Now we have a job
We do. Let's come here. And our
Here we had created a route dashboard.
Job seeker. So here you have your
You can show it accordingly. how can you show
yes? So here I call it async.
We can make it. to the correct component
cost and I say data and our
What action did we just create? it
The action was Get User Data. So here I am
I say get user data. import tax
Let's take this. We don't have to pass anything
So I will await this. Data is our
The pass will be available here. You will get the data
According to you, whatever you want to show here
You can show whatever you want here.
Correct. Here I will say data and here
Pay will come to you. So I say here
I am data dot you already have it there
Data dot user is dot here will be the name.
So you can show it accordingly. Name Joe
Whatever the name, whatever the role, whatever the type,
You can show all that. So this is me
I am copying it here. again from here
Sorry, I am not copying it completely. This
Let's copy. Walk into the recruiter's
Are. Simply paste it here.
And let's import this data.
Let's make it a sink. So I think
Guys is perfect. Ok? So both cases
Now when you login, you will see there
His name will be visible. Any user who logs in
If it is there then I think it is perfect now. So
Let's do one thing and see. So here
If we come now, look at this.
Obviously you can see it because
We already have the token in our cookies.
He is showing us his name here.
Is. So I think it's going perfectly.
Our. Ok? what do we do now
To protect the route of the guys we
People work on it a little bit. So
Now any user can access any route.
Can. Correct what we told you
Was. So now let's do one thing. I do this
I have been close. Ok? Close
We created a user action. Ok. So one
Let's work. I make one here
Here I say new file. End
Proxy dots ok? So here we are
What to do? Will take help of proxy. So
If you come here and write here
Next JS proxy
So let's move on to getting started.
So is it okay here? This one, I
I am copying. And I'm here to put this
I will paste it. Ok? So this will remain
My. And now we will make a little change in it.
Are going to do it. Ok? So this is a kind of
Let's do one thing. So better
We will pick it up from here.
clerk
A
Middleware is written here. So here
Let's go to Clerk Middle Wear. And here
Let's go. Where will it be? One second.
Here, let me take a protected route.
For. For private routes, we need
will be. So clerk middle ware protect all
Route a so I think clerk
Yahan pe hoga protect all route and hum
Guys this one is kind of config us guys
We keep ours in it. Ok? So this is better
It will remain that at that time we will need this configuration.
Here. Ok? So here we are
Let's keep the config. Ok? So what is this
Will he? This is the same for all these routes.
From will execute the middle. So now a task
Let's do it, we come here. So now
Look here, if you assume that route private
What should we do if we don't have an end token?
Will it have to? He is kind of on the login page
Will have to send it. Correct? So we have a job to do
Let's do the cost route here.
request dot
Next URL dot path name. so we have
You will find the route here. and cost is
Is protected.
So what will we do here? It's
Protected If it will be protected. Correct
Is? So it is protected. So if
There will be a protected route. So how do we
Will you take it out? So here I will say route
Dot start with what will it start with? Who
So in this we have protected route.
So what do we have here that we created?
If you go inside the app then it will be private.
We created Job Seekers and Recruiters.
So what do I say to him here?
Job
Job seekers and
Route dot start with what? Recruiters.
Ok? So here we have Itch Protected
Will get it. It means that if both of them
If any route is starting from it then it
Means he is protected. So what am I
Will I do it here? If
protected and here we will say
We will also need a token. So let's do one thing
Are. cost
token
request.cookie.get what would it say
Are we here? Token end dot value. So
What will we get here? Token. i.e
Here I will say that it is protected.
But we don't have a token. If the token
If it is not there then what will happen here? We people
What to do? Return from here and pay here
We simply copy this.
And let's paste it here. and where
Will you return it? Go to the login
You. Ok? Because that is a protected route
Is. And without token he has no access
Can do it. So where did we send you here?
Pay? He went here. Ok? And what's one more
Maybe here? that I say if
And not private. Route is not private
Can. He cannot be protected.
Ok? And here we have the token.
What would you do? Meaning that the route is public and
If we have the token then where will the user go?
Look at cost roll request dot cookie dot
Gate what to gate we have to rule dot value
Okay, let's put a question mark here.
then we get the value rule
Pay and cost URL here so now URL
Ours will be made perfect here.
I'm going to use Vectic here.
I will give him whatever role he gets.
Giving Dashboard. Now what are we here for?
do? Same thing we did with this one
We will copy and paste it here.
What will Simple do here? give the URL
I will give it to him. So I Think Now Is Perfect
They. Ok? Now whatever role he is in, if he
Try different ways to access it too
Will do. Let's say his role is something else.
If you want to access someone else then
He can't do that either. Ok? Next. So
We need to call this here pay dot next.
Ok? At the end I think now a sub
It's perfect. And if we are here
See. So look, we have already arrived.
People here. If we do one thing here
We do. So if I put a token here
Let me remove it, we will have it here, look.
These tokens. I will delete this. So
See what will happen? If I were here
If I refresh, where will I go?
On the sign in page. And when I sign in
I will do it here. So again we have a token.
Will go. So I'll sign in here.
Am.
Yes. Ok? And then I sign in
Am. And look here comes login success.
Our end happened, we are here for that
I reached the dashboard and the role that was there
This is going perfectly here again.
Ok? So these are our guys here.
It went perfectly. And I think this is right.
Now let's do one thing. Oh, I will close this
I do others. And now we have a task
We do. What did we do here? Now!
We have a private here. and one
Let's work. I'm going to take another route here.
I create a group. And I say new
Folder and I call it public. Correct
Is?
Basically I can move it inside the public
I have been. A
to the page
Layout to end this. Ok? So I move
I am giving it to the public here. and a
I think now we should do this. A
Update. I will say yes. End
Here, okay, what did we do? of the public
Okay, let's keep it right here inside.
This is global CSS within the app itself. So this
It will remain mine. Ok? So this in public
Our route here will be that no one can
can access. Ours is private. Now
Here is my layout. Ok? Private
Of the one. Ok? So now watch me do one thing
We are the people. When its layout comes here
I can put my header here.
Am. Ok? So let's do one thing. Our
There will be a header in the component here.
So now look at what we have here.
The public layout has a header. So I
If I wanted, I could have removed it here.
Are. Ok? We have the header here.
Not needed in this case. So I'm from here
I am removing it. And I want it in the layout
Header here. Ok? in private
Header needed here. So I keep it here
I give. And let's import it
From here. Ok? Now if you look at this
What will it look like? So if I say this to
I'm getting the global CSS from here.
I'm importing but can't find it
I tell him that it is not okay
If you are getting it then come here and
If you look up a little, you will find it
Okay, so from here we go, a public
If we go out, I think we should meet a
Let's see, so if we look at it now
It says body tag was not root layout
Hey, what is he saying? Ok, let's do one thing.
So so because now this is our layout
If the private one is there then he will say that brother
You can provide this thing to me also.
Two. It won't work like this without HTML body
I will render everything to you.
Yes, this won't work, right guys?
So let's remove it. would import this
It is from Tastify. And this thing gives us all this
We don't need that thing. Ok? So
Basically we remove this also so it is perfect
Is. And I think here if we look at
So our run is doing but our little
The CSS is corrupted. So because CSS
It got worse because who do we have?
If this is private then let's go privately.
Are. Here we do one thing, our own
Global CSS is what it is called
This is my global end, look everything is fine
It's gone. So if we did one thing right now
Are. We have not created the logo. Butt one
Let's work. To test, we
Let's go here. Delete your A token
We do it. Let's refresh. So we the people
Where will the guys go? We will go away
Here. A token body OK login OK us
What will I have to do again? A
Here it would be better if we
Let's create our own custom layout. Butt one
Let's work. Creating a layout here in Auth
Guys will have to. So what would be better?
What would be better is that we do one thing
Next means separate layout, we do it like this
Can be made from. Ok? But one of these
The problem will be that the more you create groups
He will have to give you his layout. So
What can we do better than that?
We we so do one thing. I am here a
I create a new folder of custom layout.
Ok? And here I say
privatesx
And here I say export cost
Private layout and will come here to me.
Children whose type will be Children
gotta react dot
React node okay so this will be and we
You will return your debt from here.
We will render here and our children
For now, we are adding it here.
He has it. Ok? So the private layout
Let's do one thing. Create a file here
We do. Index
And here we say export
Default Function
And give it a name
Custom layout. Ok? We are now in return
People give a div here.
And I say this here
Custom layout and let's come here.
Ok? So let's come here here. End
We have a private layout here.
A sorry, let's come here. And here
Will come to us. Let's do one thing here.
I will come here to you
Children and its
Children and React dot React node. Correct
Is? And here we can
Access and here we do one thing
Are.
cost path name use path name next
Navigation to End Path Name
Dot start with seekers and path name dot
Start with recruiters. Ok?
Recruiters. Ok? So we did this
Is. So here we have True Falls Mill
This will go. And what are we here for?
do? If not, can access returns. We people
What will you do simply? This one which is our
He has children, we will take him from here.
Will return it. What are we in Else?
do? We have our own private
You had made the layout, right? What will I do with this?
I will return it with this. Ok? Simple
I will give it to him here. Private
We will import this layout.
Private layout sorry private layout and
What will we do here?
Our children will come here like this. Correct
Is? So what will we do with this end?
I call this a use client. Ok?
So we did this. And I think now
It's perfect. what do we do here
Are? Now let's do one of our things. I am here
I create one inside the Pay component.
I say new file. And I say auth
Or do one thing. A header header
Let's create dotsx. Ok? already
It is defined. So we can do one thing. Header
So we will need it. So let's do one thing
No, basically. So we live here.
So here we do this one thing.
No, we use it there. And then we
What will people do? So here I say
header. Ok? Simple header this
Use the one. But what will we do?
We will handle things conditionally. a job
We do. I'm closing this now
Am. So now we can use it here.
Yes, let's do some work. while closing
Are. So now we are going to use guys here.
The ones are JT's. So in a way, the state
Management Library. We are Rux too
Could have used it. But we are going to use it now
The ones are JT's. So you have no problem with that
Will not done. Even if you don't know, you
You will understand this easily. So let's do one thing.
First, let us install it. End
Then we will use it. in the terminal
Let's go. And I say npm clear
Let's do this. npm I just. Ok?
So here we press enter.
So this will be added to our package. End
Then we can use it. So one
Let's work. Here we have a new
Let's create a folder. end of the store
Here I say new file. I say
user dot store dots okay cost user
Store is equal create karenge hum log and
We will be here and whoever comes to us
And then we here our this
We will provide whatever is ours, it is fine.
So here we say it like this
User which can also be null and here
set user
okay and here it will come to us
Let's import it first. So I
I say import create from where?
Just and Say. Ok? The set will come here
function and I use this and here it is
The function will be set up to the user. Here
Payload will come. And we will type it
I had already made it here, type it here.
So let's do one thing. I say
Export
A
Interface I User and inside this there will be User
Its type can be user or a sorry
User can be either null or null. This is why
I exported it from here.
And now let's save it here.
We will also import it. So look what we
Made here? Ah, did we miss something?
Here? Okay, yes, one second and here.
What we'll do is call this a set.
What are we going to pass in the end set?
If we want to set this user then we
What will people do, they will give it to him here
set user s and yeh data kahan pe aayega is
When someone sets the user in the payload
The data will come here in the payload.
If you call this, it will send data to it.
In the function, I will say payload here.
What will we do now to export it?
Default User Store We have created it from here
Exported okay and here we are
What do people do here?
Export
Interface I User Store. Ok? here
We will make it. be inside it
The user can either have the user type of I user
It will be of type or it can also be null.
And the second one will be set user and inside it
Will he come? Payload. What will be its type?
I user and this return
Void tax ok? Payload
Okay, and this is our perfect. So this
Look what we made simple here.
We used just and. what made
Create used the create method's just
The set of a set function from end to its end
A function will appear which you have to set for
For example, this user now has a data set here.
It will be the user's. So I have a set here.
Understand the user in a way, created a function.
Ok? So what will come here? set whenever
If someone calls him, then when I call him
If I do, how will I call? so me
If I want to call a set user, I can call him.
I will pass the data as object data like this.
Ok? So when this data comes to it then
It will say that it may be of this type. either
Can be of type user or null
Is. It means that it can either be of this type
The data can be either null here. So
I have told two. And then we
What did you do? Called it to the set. End
To set this up, we have the user
passed to. And whatever data comes to it
I set it up. It's just simple
In this. Ok? We need no action in this
No need to create a reducer. so much
It's simple, just that. Ok? So here's a
I created a user store. Simple as that
The code is written now. Ok? Now we are one
Let's work. Come here here.
And we had made one here, right here.
A component sorry here inside the app
Private in a custom layout. Correct
Is? So if we want to fetch the data here now
If so, what can we do? So we
I had already done it somewhere here. A
Let's go privately. Here at Job Seeker
You did this on it, right? So basically we just did this
Did it in the server component. So we the people
What do you do here? This is the client
Makes the component. Firstly
Clients use it and cost
And here I say set user
Because we can set the user from here.
Can. What type of this will we have?
I User Store which we already have here
It was defined. Is equal. doing a job
Are. Here we use OK to do one thing.
Are. Let's create a user store using this.
And let's import it. and put it here
Pay simple, we are importing in a way
Are. Here S
This was our iUser Store, we
Imported the set user here. End
Cost Router Use Router. Ok? so
I've called it the client component here.
created. Here we will say use
Effect. Ok? And here it is blank
I will do it. And here I make a
Cost Fetch User Data
end cost
They say race is equal, we made it so.
It was here, here, we saw it somewhere.
Yes, let me copy this and I will put it here.
Let me paste it on here, so we have this here
I had made this server action my own, so this
Let's import it here, it's called
We are sinks
Ok? And we will get a date. So I
What should I say to this here? If not data
Let's call this access risk race. Correct
Is? Response
dot a sorry response dot what do we have
Is? dot state if i don't have true
What should I do if I find it? What should I do with this?
Let's do one thing here. would have tried
He has it. And it will be better to try it.
We will keep it in try catch.
And here we throw new error
It is better to say sorry than throw new error.
Use toast. Ok? Toast Dot Error
In error we will have whatever errors dot
Message. Ok? A message we have
Are you returning from there? Now!
Look well so oh so
If any error occurs. ok yes i think
Will come. So let's do one thing. For now I
I will tell him that yes brother, he will come.
Ok? message if a is false then message
It will come to us because only if it is true, we
People are sending it here. and look throw
We are throwing messages from here.
Are. So we have it here automatically.
Should come. Ok? It will definitely come. Look at this
We did it here. end everything if
If it's coming out well, we'll call him.
And what will you do with it? This which our
Pass race is dot data, we use it here
This is the data, we sent it from here, yes
Sorry user we have rest dot user
I'll give it to him, okay, so let's see.
Let's do rest dot here okay because
We gave him Annie, so if you rest
If you do user then you will get user there.
Because we have sent the user here.
We have done this and now look here
But what is he saying, did we miss something?
ok yes what are we doing in try and catch
We will make an error, an error will come to us and an error will come
I will copy and paste it again.
Again he will say tell me ERR then ERR
Let us give it to him and again
Let's do it for now. Ok? So
We will call it here. Correct
Is? We called here. what is this saying
Are you with us? is an async function. So better
It will remain that we are ok. Sorry. So one job
We do.
Let's call him. And I think now this
What is the use of a router? See. So here
If we assume that its status is false
Went. As soon as it fails here, we will
We will use cookies here.
Cookie. Ok? So first we have to import
have to do it. So you can import it here.
Are. Import
from js cookie. Ok? So from here we
Let's remove the cookie dot. End
Here we will remove the token. And here
What will we do? like token is removed
What should we do if it goes away? So I
I will tell you here where to go router dot push
You go? On the login page. I this
I will send you here to the login page.
Ok? And from here instead you can go down
Go. Return from here. So this is more
It will be better. Ok? So I think it's perfect
This is it. Ok? And let's do one thing at a time
We people. One component here
Where is the folder here? Ok? So here
Then I create a new file and I
I say loading dots a main loading
Are. Ok? Main Loadings Export
default function main
Loading. Ok? So this will be my main
of loading. And what can I do simply?
I am, right? Look at what we just made.
Here, I take a state here.
Cost a one-time loading set
Loading and using state faults do this
It is in default and I will do it here
Set loading to true and as soon as
will finally
Finally, I will do it here.
Falls and what can I do with this here?
Now if loading is true then here
Return it from what our main
loading tha main loading component uske i
I am returning it here, keep it simple.
Okay, so the main loading here we created that.
Now we can use it anywhere.
I shared it here and kept it
ok perfect we will see if we change
I want to do it, we will change it but ah
For now, let's leave it at that.
what people can do so we have here
I had already used the header. Correct. So
We come here. Let's do one thing.
You will have to log in. So from here
And want to end I say sign in. So
Let's see if there is any problem. This much
We wrote all the code. Log in to our
It was successful. And here we have
I have already arrived. So now we have the header here.
You can change the . what are they saying
We? A is saying something about what you did
Yes, this is a mismatch. Language also
You have used this here. So,
There is a hydration error. So, let's do one thing
Are. Hydration error, right? a job
We do. So let's come here here.
What did we have? Ah, here we have
This is a layout error, right? So, for now
I am removing this. first and sorry
Let's end this and see if there are any more errors.
What about this? I think now it's fine guys.
Correct is fine. Ok? So now we are
Login here. So I'm going to put this in my header.
Let's go. Oh, let's remove this, right?
We don't need all this. right now everyone's
There is no need. There is no need for this either.
There is no need for this either. Roast container then
We will need it. Ok? So this happened.
And now let's move on to our header. Ok?
So where do we have it? Here is the header. So here
But what can we do now? that user
You can access the . So first access
Let's do it here. So I say cost
What will I get here, where will the user come from?
It will come now, see, so I will call it i user
What type will be stored here? Use user
store this is what we built use a okay
We made it wrong, gave the name wrong, guys
Sorry sorry sorry sorry use was this use
Because we missed you here too
will have to pay the beans
This will be the use user store and not the user user
Store
Okay, so we've done that and we have
what will come here what will the user type
will be
s again save ok type very
This is important when you are using TypeScript.
so now we have here
Pay user will either be there or not when not
What will happen if it happens? It means that the user will login.
If not, what can I do here?
Here we are showing the sign right now.
in. Now if we are signed in then what should we do?
Is? And if it is not there then what to do? So
What can I do here? conditionally
If I say, first of all, here I
I say if the user is. Ok? If the user
So here I have a different component
I can show you what I make
Now. Ok? And then I came here
I will import it. So what are we here for?
Can you do it? Now a different component is shown
Can. What's ours in Else
Will remain. Ok? So here's a different
Component We do one thing. made
Let's take it. So I say yes here.
account
A header A
header a menu
A user menu dotsx okay? User Menu
dots so now when the user goes to the menu
So if he is a recruiter then different
The menu will appear. If he is a job seeker then he
A different menu will appear. So that's us too
We will do it here also. Ok? So here I am
But I am telling you, I will do it right now. Ok?
export default
Function. Ok? So here I have a
The user will come. Ok? So I would say user
Menu
The end will come here. Ok? So right now we
You can also pass it here as a props.
Are. And I can also use it directly here.
I can access it.
So it would be better to watch it here.
Are. You can access it directly here
Are. And I say here. Ok?
We imported it here. And I
What am I going to do here?
Look, if we keep it simple like this. if not
User a sorry yes if user then here so
We will definitely have users. Ok? So this
Wala it means will render only when we have
Here is the user. So if there is a user, then we need a user
Data of will also be required. So that is what we
Took it out. So let's return here
What to do? Let's take a div here. So
Let me quickly define this.
Log out. Ok? So this is what we just did with a user
Created a menu component. Ok?
In which we have used set CN
Is. And we already imported it.
It has happened. If the user is not there then from here
I am returning it. And if the user is
Will come down. We have found the rule. If the job
Is it Sikar or are there recruiters here? Correct
Is? Is job seeker is recruiter. here
We capitalized the first letter like this
Used the dropdown. Where from again? set
Ours that we used which set cai
From there it's okay and evertarget set from there
ok from cn you can install from there
You can use it by adding it, so we did the same
Installed it and then used it.
Okay, what is LasX for? This is our
For icons, so all these icons are a kind
So now understand it, okay, then some more.
It is not right, we have made a rule in this
Dropdown Again Sets Used End Here
But we capitalized the first letter.
Gave
And then if you come here, we will show you your name.
Diya and showed his email. if you
If you want to show it, you can remove it.
yes. We can just delete the email. Correct
Is? Let me see how it is here first.
Seems like Then we will remove him. Correct
Is? If you are a job seeker then this menu will be visible.
Now again what can you do with this? a one
You can configure the menu in any way you like.
And then import it from there and use it.
You can. If there is a recruiter, this will be visible.
Enter Down and Then Here Pay Profile
The setting is common for everyone. And if you get this
If you want to remove it, you can do so. Correct
Is? So what will I use here? Now
We quickly created this menu.
Let us use it here, user
to the menu.
Here comes the user menu and click on it.
Let's import the menu here. So
I think let's go here and see.
There is no problem. So what does this say
This is our use store use client okay
Okay, okay, I think what we created here is this.
What do we have to do here?
This will have to be made a client component.
Ok? So I did this. So look at me
So it would have been better if we had stayed here together.
I would have made a component and put it in, which would have been ah
In a way, the client component instance that this
Make the whole. Ok? So that's much better
There will be an approach. So here I am, making another one.
I take it. A component I don't make this
Am. I don't know all the components
I will make it. Let's do one thing. A yes. Correct
Is. I don't make all the components.
I am going to. A client component instanced that
Let me create a component here. A
New file I say account.sx
Am. Ok? I'm saying account dots
Ok. Header yes ok. And I am
No, this is all our code here.
This is all our code.
I am calling it copy here. End
I export here
default function
A
Private menu is called like this. Private
Menu. Ok? Yes.
And accordingly. Ok? Whatever remains. So
Let me import it here. A
And then what will I do with this? this here
Pay use client first
The client will use it. And take it from here
We will remove it.
We will import it here. because now
We need to call this same part as the client component.
Had to make it, not the whole thing. Ok?
We will import everything and use it.
It will become simple. Ok? end this too
Our button as well. Ok? So we have all
Some were imported here. I Think Now
It's perfect. And we have to return that
We made a mistake here. This is how to do it
Us. And here it is like this, sorry
Down here. Ok? Here. Ok?
So let's come here. So what is he saying
Is? Ok. Ok. If I have this user
So if I have a user, I'll do this.
Otherwise they remove it and the link.
We will import it. Ok? so sorry here
Let's do it from.
And import the next link from here.
Let's take it. And this is much better. Ok
Guys? Because now we have to understand the whole
The component has a private menu called
Let's make it. Simple will be better.
Ok? And now what should we use here?
do? Instead, we don't need this
Is. So let's remove this. This is the client
We will not make the components. And this
Shall we use simple here? which this
Our component is private menu. Correct
Is? This one. Ok? So I think now
It's perfect. You can see it is much better
that I can transfer all the components to the client
Create a component. What was better that
I create a component that I
I will create a client component. and inside it
I will write my logic like this. And that
It is much better. Ok? Now here when
If you come here, this is ours. like this
It is defined. Ok? So if we now
Let's see if it is giving any error. If
Let us refresh it once, it is still there
Showing sign in. Do we have users?
Not logged in? And what if I am logged in?
Not set? So this could be that. Correct
Is? Where did A go to us? doing a job
Are. Here we go to our jobs.
On the Seekers one. Ok. Job seekers.
[music]
And we had this layout here.
Fetch Data
And what do you have to see guys that this is fake
It is not happening. Ok. A I think I think we
I have missed something. which is our
This is the layout, we do one thing with it.
Are. I say it here
The custom layout we created included wrap
We do it. This will be much better, right?
So we have one right here. Now if
If we come here, then if I
refresh now
This compiling end
Let's see if our API is called.
Is it happening or not? So that one second here.
But let's move on. Oh yes, look, this one is here.
No. So if we click here
So look, this is how it will look to us. This one
The name was. This was an email. If the email is like this
If you want to keep it, you can remove it. So here
Let's do one thing, instead I'll send you an email.
Should I show you? So let's come here. I am simple
What can I show you now? Ah, because this
Our menu is the user menu here.
I can show instead of email its role. So
I will show you the role here. Ok? A so
If you look now, what do you see here?
Will you see? Whoever he is, he will be a job seeker. So one
Can work. A
So instead of showing Job Seeker like this, you
What can you do? You can map this
A instead that show it that way. So you are a
Write the function util function and there
Show him A. A as you want to show.
So let's do one thing. Ah, he is here, right?
Util function. So I'm going to create a function here.
I make it. Export Function
And change get role.
Let's roll it up. And here
The role will come to me. And I am here
Will I return it? Ah Switch Switch Switch
Let's file a case. switches it on
This. The roll will come to us. Ok?
If the role is equal and equal I will say
Job
Seekers what to do if this is the return that
You also have to do
Job Seekers and if in case we have
Roll Sorry Roll
Equal and Equal
Recruiters, so what can you do simply?
return this return this
Capital
There will be a recruiter, then there will be a job seeker.
Okay, so either he will be a job seeker or
The recruiter will be able to do it here.
Ise Recruiter and Default
End return to default two rolls
Okay, so the type of this is string end.
Now what is he saying, I am ok ok equal
Let's make it equal, okay. what is he saying
Do we have it? A Bullion Is Not OK
equal to sorry
So the gate will roll. And what are we here for?
do? You can call it now. A us
So I will call here. where did you go
My? Here it is. So if I put this here
Let me call it like this by user dot roll
In this way, by rolling user dot, then user and
The roll will come here and if you look now then
You will see the job seeker here like this
Okay, look guys, as much as you can
Accordingly you think you will make it much better.
It will be fine, so this is how we did it.
Now our name is visible here and this
It looks like this to us, so let's do one thing.
Look, the highlights are not visible yet.
So you can highlight it a little bit.
How can our atar be seen here?
If I consider this a variant ghost. So
See what variant it has guys. GOST
is, default, destructive, outline
Yes, what if we do an outline?
Will it remain?
So it will look like this which is not correct
Guys. It must have looked absolutely awful. So
We can change that. A your
Accordingly, as now we have to do it, then atar
You can do this by conducting classes etc. But
Let's leave it for now. Ok? So now
That's enough for this. When we have to change
If it happens, we will change it later. But
If we are logging in now, we
See if I log in from Job Seeker
If I do it, it will look different. If I am a
If I do it through a recruiter, it will look different. So
This way we have these things here
I achieved it. We haven't got the logo yet.
has made. We will see that. Ok?
perfect. So let's come here. Right now we are
Let's close this. Ok? And here
Let's come. Let's come here. We people make this
Let's close it. Ok? So this is ours now
There is a folder structure. Ok? So here
When we come, it looks like this to us.
Ok? So here we are getting some error.
Is. Ok. Ok. So if we log in from here
If they get us out then we will come here.
If I go to the home page, we will see
The header is visible. When we are here at home
Let's go to the page and see how it looks.
Is. When you go to the home page, it looks perfect.
Used to be. But our guys don't have headers here.
It looks like it doesn't seem right. Correct
Is? How can I show the header? So we
What simple thing do I have to do? If we people
We have to show the header because the header is visible
It is important there. So we our
What can I do here in the layout? Header
Can show. Ok? Your header. Correct
Is? Which we already made because here
We handled things conditionally.
It has happened. So we will see the header here.
But what will be the problem now? look like
If I log in then we will have a problem.
Will happen.
Ok? And now when I log in
It might be a problem to see us here.
That double header was visible. So why is this visible now?
Used to be? Because in the private layout
Maybe we did it here, not here
Used here in custom layout here
But we have ah this header here is okay
And the second one is our private layout.
There was a private layout here.
We do not use multiple nested HTML.
You can do it, it will also give you error.
what to do put in simple dib because
Our root layout here in the parent.
It is there, it is ours. Ok? So now
If we look at it, look at it right now.
Rendering is taking place. If we log out
Even if we do it, he is still watching us.
Now even if we go to the home page, our
It's going well, which is perfect. Correct
Is? So we had logged out this.
A I think so why are we seeing this
Guys from this? ok i think what should we do
Will it have to? So he will have to do that once. Correct
Is? We will refresh it and see. him we
People will fix it. Ok? So that one
It will be ours to fix it later.
do. So for now, our folder
The structure is something like this guys. Ok?
Now what should we do guys that we should get jobs
Have to show. So what do we do for that?
Will it have to? For that, first we need to create a table.
Will fall. So here comes our super
In the base. And right now I have a user here.
There is a table of. So I'm going to do something here.
Am. I'll make a new table. And I say
I am all
Jobs. Ok? So, I'm saying all
Jobs. And you define your columns here.
You can do it. So by default here
Created at. So I say here
Add and here I say recruiter
The underscore will be the ID. Ok? So we
People give intent because it will happen
What? The reference ID will be one way. So
And let's add a column here. And here
What will happen on it? Title. what is the job title
will be? Ok? So here and what about it
Will we give it? Text. Ok?
And what will happen here in the same way?
Description.
Job description. We will text this too
We do it. Let's add it. saying here
There are locations. What will be the location of the job? So
Let's text this here as well. End
Similarly, job type. So here it says
job type and this is what we call it
There will be text. After that float at. His
Max salary will be later.
We will float it also. float
At. Ok? And after that it will be ours
Experience. Ok? So the experience is
We will keep it. Experience
They say it is required. And we also
What do people say? In float et. Correct
Is? Let's add the last
Date. Ok? Last date a ok? Last
date to
Let's apply this. Will this happen?
There will be a date. So this date type will be this. End
And here we are, skills are fine.
There will be skills. So what will this be? text
So there can be skills or there can be multiple
Can. So what can we do here?
Are? Sorry, I will come here. And this
will be define as array array. Ok? So this
Will remain and add. We the people say
Status. Ok? What will be the status? again
Text. So what will remain of me? of the job
column of the table. Ok? Created at Job Cub
Was it created? Recruiter ID will be that of
Did the recruiter create this? From one side
There will be a reference. This title is a job title,
What is the description, job location? What
What type of job is it? Minimum Salary, Maximum
What is the salary and experience required?
What is the last date to apply for this job?
What skills are required for this?
What is the end status of the job? enable disable
Or whatever we have to do now? here
Have to come down. Add for key relation. So we
Relationships will also have to be set here. So
What if this table of ours is created?
The job that will be created within this will be any
If the recruiter himself creates it, then we will
You will have to build relationships here. So I
What do I say here? This is our user
There is a profile. And come here. So
Public call job. So what will happen here?
My recruiter ID will be there. and its relation
Who will it be with? This will be our ID.
Ok? This will be our ID. So this
Our relation will be of the user profile which
User profile it means that recruiter to
His relationship will remain with this one. So now this
It will keep you in sync which recruiter has applied for this job.
has been created. Ok? So this is a
So what did we do here? From one side
Relation created this table as User Profile
With a table of. Ok? Now we are here
What will you do? Let's save this. End
Create your table here.
Are. So here we have an all jobs
Our table has been created here again.
And we have also defined its relation.
Correct. Who is it related to? own
This is the user profile table. Ok? So
What do we have to do here? RLS Policy
Let's add this too. A says here
We are the ones who create policies. So here all
A Permissions
All permissions with all permission and here
True. And we do this too.
True. So all permission with ah I mean all
Permission with all users. Ok? So here
What will we do with it? Save policy. So
For this our RLS policy is available here.
We added pay here for the table. Correct
Is? I did it all. Ok? So let's go
We are here, sorry, where did our job go?
Our job table? Go to your table editor
Are. So here is our job table.
Let's come here. Now we are about our jobs.
We also define the type of the table we created.
Can do. Correct? So, come here
Are. So, what can I say here?
Export Interface
And I will say I job job okay job say
Let us give it and what will happen here
Our ID will be of string type end
The recruiter will have a recruiter ID, this will also be
string apna end title hoga string
Description
This will also be a string
The end location will also be our string job
What will be our type?
This will also be my string minimum salary
What will be the number
What will be our maximum salary?
Experience
What will be our string required?
What have we defined here?
Here we have
Experience Required Last Date To
Apply Correct Last Date to Apply Our
what will this be my string this will be
Skill will also be a string. And here
What will be our status? String. Correct
Is? String Sorry
Created underscore at what will this even be?
What will the string updated at be? This too
will be the string. Ok? saving this
Are. Now take your action here too.
Let's create it. what we have here
You made an action, right? So here we are
What to do? new file j dot
Jobs.actions.
Ok? So here job related action
All of us will be there. So what am I here for?
Will I say? This was our what? This is what will happen
User related actions will be done here. Correct
Is? And what will happen here? from the job
There will be related actions. Ok? So therefore this
You can separate it here in a way
to things. Ok? So to find things
It will be easy for me. If anyone comes
He will know that this user is good here.
If there is an action, then from as many users as
There will be related actions and functions.
It will be inside it. Ah and here is the job
Those related to this will be inside it. Correct
Is? So like this. So what are we here for?
We do? Export cost create job.
Ok? So what am I saying here?
Create job. What will happen to me here?
will be an infinite function. What will come here
We have? Payload. Look, the payload will come. So
Look again at what we just defined.
Type so many when someone will create a job
So will you give me all these things? For him
Created at is updated. This will definitely happen
No. You have Updated at Created at
Correct. At that time, we were here
What to do? Here we are partial
What will we do here in partial?
What will we tell him? I
The iJob that we just created
This type. Ok? So what is this now?
He will understand that something is coming from inside this
Things will come. It means that not everyone will come
This type. Not all will be there. But out of this
There may be some things. Nothing can happen.
So now he will consider everyone as optional.
Ok? So we have partially defined it here.
Used it. And we have the payload here.
Will come. And here we will say try
Here we will say catch.
And here we will have an error. Ok?
And here we cost race
Await
Hey, what did we have here? Here we are
Let's create it. First of all, super bass.
Ok? Sorry. Yes. First we have super bass
You will have to create it. import it
Will have to. Ok? We import from here
Let's do what we made. and then
Cost Race and what will we say here?
Await
Two Pabes
Dot from what is our all
Jobs
aha what is he saying
Okay Superbot All Jobs dot insert
What to do in insert this one in it
The entire payload is one, whatever comes
From there we'll insert it here.
We will get a response here, whatever
It must be his. Ok? And here we are
What to do? If I say race dot sorry
Dot E error. Ok? what are we here
Will you say? throw
New error and rest dot error dot message.
Ok? So let us throw this from here.
Will give. What if there is an error?
do? What will we do in return?
We will make its status true here. End
What will we say in the message? Jobs
Created. Ok? Like this. So here
We will give it this way. And again we
If there is an error in some catch then people
We can give it in this way. Ok? These
It will be RR. Ok? Either we do a job
Let's do it, let's send him here.
In a way they make a false statement. And here
We just give a simple dot message.
Ok? So this is perfect. This is our action
One is ready here. Ok? Now here
But what do we do? export cost
Get Job
Bye ID is fine and what will this also be sync
The function will be end here like this okay
What will come here, we have job ID
what will be its type number ok job id
what will be the type of number here and I
I will say try again, we are the same here.
Tell your superbase to create a client
Will end cost
Race this super base dot from here
what will you say all jobs okay all jobs
dot select what will we say here
Star it means that Sahara dot equal equal
Whose ID should this be?
This should be equal to the job ID, so what?
He will find a job from there and take it.
I will come and then if I check here
I will take if response dot error a sorry error and
response dot data dot sorry data dot use
We will have to wait there.
length equal and equal if zero then we
What will people do here, will they cry?
New
Error will say job
no job job found ok and isko kya
have to do it
Now we have to wait, okay then Sara
Our end is perfect, assume everything went well
So what will we return here?
Will return here status to be
What do we have in the data in this case?
This will be the job data, sorry, this one.
The response is okay so this is our perfect
okay what will we do in try and catch
We will get an error here, simply copy it.
We do.
And here we are, this falls
Will go. And what will we say here?
An error message will appear. Ok? So this
Our gate is done. So this was our what?
Create job. What has happened to me? Get Job
By ID. Ok? And here we are, a
And to create Export Cost Edit Job.
Ok? We will do editing jobs here.
So will this also happen? There will be a sync function
Our.
Ok? What will we give him here? Async.
Now if someone edits the job, he will tell
Not which job is editing, so that
What do we have to give? The ID of that job.
So here I will call it job ID.
Whose type will be number. And now in that job
What do you want to edit? so it means
That he will edit something inside it. So his
The data will be of this type. I take this
I will take it. from this, from this job, from this
There will be something from the field in it. Correct?
That's why we have partial load here in Pei Load
I told him about my type. Ok?
Interface. Now he will understand that from within
Something or the other will happen. something different from the outside
Cannot be done. Ok? If he is from outside
If something happens it will give an error. So here we have it
Created it. And then we are here
Will say try again. And here we are again
People will call this their own. Ok?
End Cost Res Await
to base dot from here what will happen to me
All
unders jobs hai alljobs dot update ok
What the update will do is this payload which
It will come but update it and give the full payload
If you give it then whom will you update, that too
So if he asks, we will tell him who we consider equal.
If it should be equal then it has to be updated.
I will tell you this, this ID
Must be equal to the corresponding job ID
So what will this do to this job ID?
Whatever happens, its payload will be updated.
If you respond to us here then we will come again
People will check here if response dot
Suppose there is an error, if there is any error then new error sorry
error res dot sorry
rash dot error dot what will be the message
So whatever message will be here, return it from here.
If it is not done then what will we do with the return?
From here we will make the status true and here
If we have a message then we will say message
Job
Updated
Ok job updated successfully
Simple Isi Ko in Successfully and Else
copy it and paste it here
So here our error will be dot
Message and status will be false in this case
In. So here we have these three actions also
We have made it so far. Ok? So create
He can do it, he can edit it. Create now
Can do. Can get that job. That
Can edit the job. Delete it too
He can do that job at any time.
Ok? So we make that too. So
Let's do one thing here. Export
cost
Delete job. Ok?
This will be the sync function.
And what will we do here? again this
Let's all copy this. Ok? A
Should I copy this completely?
It will remain the same. But just make a small change
We will give it here. So inside all jobs
Will go. What will he do here? delete that
will delete it here and it will be equal
of this job ID. So here we have
Job ID will come which will have number. this error
If it does, an error will be returned. Jobs
It will be deleted. It will be done successfully.
here
Your Job
Your job.
Ok? Deleted successfully and thus
The message will be sent. Ok? So, here we are
What did you say? That go to this table. delete it
Two jobs. Which job whose ID is this
Whatever happens, we will pass from here. Correct
Is? So here we created the delete job.
of, edit job of and get by id job of,
of create job. Now we get all here.
Jobs. You can get all the jobs too.
User. So what will we do here?
Export Cost Get Jobs. So Joe Get Job
If it will happen then
Gate Recruiter Jobs.
recruiters recruiter jobs ok get
There will be a recruiter job because I will tell you now.
Ok? Meaning a recruiter who creates jobs
If he has done it, he can also get his job.
Is. So that's why we have a like this here
Created the function. Ok? A sink and here
Simply what do we do? This is what we
People copy the ID.
Ok? Because what will happen here? Here
Pay aayega humaine pass recruiter ID. Ok?
Its type will be number and this is us here
But we will pass this and its here
What ID do we have there recruiter
The underscore ID is probably what we've given it.
So let's take a look here.
What have we given, so we have written here
Here is the ID description
Yes, what is this given, we have seen it here.
If we take it, this is what is given to us, so we have
It will come here, what did we say, select it.
Do whatever jobs he has here and we
Give it to get the job here, I will send you my ID.
And he will give it to him, if not then the job
If there is no data then I will give it, otherwise
This error and here is perfect dot data o
Sorry, I think we missed it here.
Not here, not even here, this one
Dot data will be here
Okay, so we did it and it's perfect.
Ours is fine, so the delete one also became a gate.
Dot job has also become ours, now what are we
Guys, we do this on the front end.
Let's also make this excerpt.
I have defined it. Correct. Now we are here
Come on. Here in the end components
Come to the app. And come to private
Are. So recruiter. Ok? So here we are
People file a new file here. I
I say jobs and page dots. So this is our
A rout ensued. So job a yahan pe user
Can see. Ok? perfect. Now when the job
If he can see, he can also create a job.
So here again, within this, I say
am add and
A says create job
Create page dots so here we job
You can also create it. Correct Perfect
He can create jobs and also view jobs.
what can he do to the job
He can also edit it, so here we are.
Let's do one thing. am so job hai and new
Let's file it. I say edit and
It will come to us here ID and here
what will happen my page dotsx okay what is this
This will be our ID, sorry, this will be here.
ID our dynamic pagex so if we guys
Look here, so like this inside the edit
This one will be dynamic end page dotsx okay
So this is how we can make it here.
Are there any edit, create and delete
We can already do it there.
Okay, so we showed you the toaster.
Defined. So perfect. Here we are
Let us define it also. remove this this
Are. Ok? So here I say
export default function
Create job. Ok? And return in hum
People keep simple divs for now. End
I say create job. and in the same way
Edit
Let's come here. Edit job.
Ok? Edit here as well
And I'm done editing my creation, what is this?
My Job All Jobs
All jobs okay so we made this an all
I have got a job, this is ours already.
It has a dashboard which is perfect. Correct
Is? So we have defined it here. So
If we come here, how will we
Will I get to see it? So let's do one thing.
First, we would log in with the recruiter.
Are. First of all, we need the recruiter to help us
There is no user nearby. So let's sign up
From a user. So I'll quickly sign here.
I click on up. And I say
here a
Let's name him Mohit. Mohit.com
We do it. And here too we are one
I will give you the number. And I call it that.
So what will it do here? Our account
This will also be created which will be the user here.
Register successfully as our user here
It has been registered. So basically what do we
Should have done it? When the user registered
By email, send it to us on the login page
should give. That will be much better. So one
Let's work. Is it registered? So when this
Success is happening here. So here we
The one with success is shown on it. So I
I use the router here. Ok?
here
Use router from next navigation and we
What will people do here, where will he be?
We will send it when it is successful, push the dot
Where will I give it to him on login, okay, so this
Where will it go when it is registered?
This will take you to the login page.
So we did it now it's perfect so now we
People also log in and see here.
Let's go to your sign in then I say
am at a b cd.com was. And here I am
What will I do? And I am a recruiter.
Sign in Okay. Ok. Am I think we here
I missed something on the login page.
We will come down a little here. So here
here here here here here here here
We will have to do yes. So let's come here.
And here
ABCD.com
here
End recruiter signs in. And we
People should sign in here. log
These became successful. So where are we here?
Are you gone? There are recruiters. So the recruiter
Went to the dashboard. Correct. here
What do we see? Recruiter Dashboard.
It's perfect. Now look at us here, we have this
Route was created. Inside Recruiter
Job. So if we go here, recruiter
Inside I say job here. Job
Is. Isn't it? Do we have jobs? If I
If I press enter, what do we see here?
Needed? a ok sorry job jobs jobs
Recruiters and Jobs Recruiters Jobs a
The base of jobs is here. here
What is ours? Okay, now, I think we
Guys this is here inside the recruiter
Needed It is created inside the dashboard.
Went. That is the problem with it. Ok? oh yes
Set set set sh that was the problem. I Think Now
We have come to Perfect on All Jobs. same
Like us here, what were our jobs?
Here? Create. So if I'm here
Write Jobs and with this was here
Create. So here we are on create job
Will come. We are here to create a job.
Pay. We edit in the same way. So here we are
People will write edit. Suppose I edit it
Will give. Edit Sorry and I am here 1 2 3
I will give anything. So here it is
Will you go? Edit job. Ok? So edit
We have come to the job. So Route So
We are doing perfectly right now. Ok? End
What do we have to do now? Now we here
But it will have to be defined. Firstly
Create edit is ours. So let's do one thing
Are. A let's create a component here.
Let's take it. I file a new one.
Job form dots do this. Export
Default Function
Job Form. Ok? So, here we are
What are you making? Job Forms and Returns.
So, here we are going to basically use
Which one is it? Component Ah Set CN of Set CN
section of UI with many components and
Then we're going to use some editor.
I will use a simple editor. Ok? So
Make it quickly. And Jord also we people
Are going to use it. So let's do one thing
Let's quickly define open. Ok? So
This will be my look schema title is like this
Will remain. We are using the joint.
and then description, location, job type,
Minimum salary, maximum salary,
How much experience should one have? last date
How much is the application? What is skill? Status
And this and we put dot refine here.
It has happened. Look, now we planted it because
What will be the minimum salary and what will be the maximum salary
If it is less than the minimum then it cannot be greater than the minimum.
It cannot be small, so we have put it here.
It is installed in this way. If that accident
If it does, we get an error like this here
Will be seen. Ok? So here it
We will see the error. So this
It's perfect. What do we give here?
Yes, Mensley. Ok? And then we here
I have defined my type with this. on Z.in
From here I defined the type. and then
We have entered all this in the default values
Is. Ok? What could the job be? Full
It could be full time, it could be part time.
Could be remote. All this cut and then this
It's all there. The status is open. will see this
If we want to close it or pause it
All that remains. Ok? perfect. So
We have defined all of this here.
Schema and this one. Ok? class name
What do you give? turn the container over
Are. Ok? So this will be my container.
Here we use card header.
Where from again? Our set of CN
Is a component. Ok? Sorry. Ok? So this
My card will remain and then we here
Pay card title used inside which
There will be a create job. and the paragraph inside it
Inside which its description is simple
Like. Ok? So this is what we have from Again Set CN
Guys, it has been used. Ok? set cn
What can you do with it from there? A
When you install the card from here,
If you add them, you will have all these components.
Will also come. And simply you are inside her
Whatever you have to write after setting up your class
Whatever you want to add, you can do it.
yes. Ok? Here we are
We also use our separator.
Already. Again, where did we get this separator from?
Have you taken it guys? Again you can see
We have taken the separator from our UI. Ok?
So set from CN. Ok? So set in CN
You can find everything. install it
You can use it and simply
Is a component. Ok? Card Contents. Correct
Is? The content of the card will appear here.
And then we'll say padding here.
Let's write the class. We will give this a little bit
Padding is given from the top. Six. Ok?
So this is how the end is, I think it's perfect.
Ok? So if we look at it now, we
It should look something like this. See what they say
If he is still here, what does he say to us?
Used to be. So I think we missed something
What? Now look guys. Ok? So like this
From here we will see Create Job Post
And this will be our detail. And this is our
There will be a separator. Ok? And now we are here
Pay defines your card content.
Let's use the form here. Again we
Which again, where do you get this form from?
will get? From Sets Chain UI. Again we
Look, it is used from here. Ok?
And let us define it here.
First of all, change the form. Ok? So this
My form will remain. We have defined it.
Where to use the form? Look here again
Used from React Form. And I took this
I told you that we have already defined this type.
Already done. We have typed this out.
Have taken it. And here in resolver your
This one passed the schema. end default
In value we have already set the default value
It is defined here. default
This will be our value of the form. And this
When will it work? On Change Pay. whenever something changes
If it happens, then it has a kind of form
There will be a validation check. In a way, understand it like this.
Ok? So this has been defined. And this
What do we have to do? here here we
What will people do? We will pass it this way.
We gave him our form.
Form. Ok?
Here we will use HTML form.
Use on submit end class here
I will do space here, I will make it six.
Okay, and we'll see to it.
We will do this, we use it here.
We will fill the form field and quickly I will fill it
I'll define it, okay, so this will be it.
My form field inside this we have control
Passed did you pass the form dot control
given inside it and in the name of this
The field name will be Title what will render
Inside it? This field item. of field items
Inside we rendered the form level.
The level of the form will be the job title. End
Inside this we have entered input in form control
rendered inside which like this our
The input will appear. So how will you see it?
It should look something like this. what is this saying
Are you with us? Ok. A ok he is saying
We will have to provide this. So one
Let's do the work, right? I'll just move on.
I will give it to him. Let's come here. End
Okay, what do we need to do here first?
Guys? So
UseClim. Ok? Now I Think Perfect
Must be rendered. If I refresh
So let's see what he says. Look at this here
What will the job title be? provide in this way
Have to get it done. Ok? Software in the example
Engineer. Ok? Let's come here. End
What do we have here? This one
Field. Again we have multiple fields like this
We will define it from. So I will say it here
Form fields. Again because multi-second
We have to take the field. This is how I define
I will do it quickly. control here
Form dot what will we do? control
Benefits. Ok? So this is what we have said here
What we did here was create a form.
Created form fields. Inside this we have not
Will take the description. So in the description
What can he do? to any text
Can highlight. to any text
Can add to heading. someone over there
Can add to the list. So for that we
Here's a text editor component
has made. Ok? So here if I
Let me show you. So this is our Rich here.
The text editor in which we have
I have used Quick's library. Correct
Is? So basically when you go inside it
You will get the code there easily. So we
I used the same here. And here
In a way, we took the reference of dip
Returned it. Ok? So here we have
Its passed text area. And when you
You will see here, so we have kept it simple here.
What have you done? Input here here
Rich text editor is used. Value On
What will happen to the change? What's in the place holder?
Want to show? And that's everything. Ok?
What is the level of the form, what is the control of the form
Want to keep it? He is here. and then form
Item. Ok? Control in End Control
And description is its name. Ok? So
If you look at it, it will look something like this.
Ok? Something a bit like this.
I mean, look at this, it's a little bit cut off here.
It is visible. So what do we do for this?
Can you? Wait a moment, inspect this
Let's see what class it has? QL
There is a container. So if we take a little bit of this
If we give margin top minus here then
margin-top - 8 pixels
Apx so I think is perfect. Correct.
Yes. So let's come here. And we are our
Let's add it to global. here
Should we add it? If I make this
If I go to margin top - 8 pixels. Ok?
So if we refresh our eyes here,
So that should go on. Are you not taking it? A
Let's see what he says.
So this is it, this will remain mine. And this is mine
I am not taking classes. Ok? So he will take it. So
Basically, we just need to do something simple.
This is important here.
Ok? So now is perfect. And look at this
Ours is going well. Ok. So our
Here the title and description are also done.
It also happened. What do we do now guys?
What else will we have? The title is done,
The description is done. Here we have
What all have been defined? The title is done,
Description, location. Ok? So, this
So let's close it. And here is your
Let's take the form fields quickly. I say
am form field.
What is in control of this here?
will be? Form dot controls give gaps
Six it a little bit. Ok? So here
We will keep this control.
here and here
Okay, so if you look at it now, it looks like this.
What we'll see is the location right here.
So the location will be visible here and here
what can we do second one here
Let's take it again, I'll say form field
And again, will we give him control?
Form dot control end here in control
But what do we have to give in name only?
What will you give him? Job Underscore Type
Remote. Ok? So this will be my job type.
Control form control end here
Let's see. So this is how my job will be.
Type. So Full Time Contract Internship
What kind of remote job type is that? Ok?
perfect. Let's come here. Here we are
Let's take another div inside which
In grade class. Ok? give a gap again
Let's give him a little. How much? Six Tax
Let's give it a gap. Ok? again we are
We will use the form field here.
end control form dot control value s
Number so if you see so this is our minimum
Our form field will be for salary, so here
If you look at it, you will see something like this.
So if I refresh, there's some problem.
No Guys
A let's see I think it's perfect so here
But we come here in the same way.
What will you do by defining the maximum salary also?
I will take it here quickly, so I am here.
What can I say, Max?
And here will be Max
And here it is perfect. Ok?
Our maximum salary control is perfect.
remains. In this way the minimum salary and
Maximum salary can be added here. They
Correct, perfect. So let's come here. again
Here we take a due. Correct
Is? Here they say class grade gap de
We give. Let's give a gap six here.
So let's keep it common. Again here we are
People their form field years. Ok? So
This will be my year. Ok? So it will remain
What about me? Of experience. Experience
How much is required for this job? So
If you look at it, it will look something like this
You will see a dropdown of experience level. So
Whatever remains, you can select it from here.
yes. As much experience as he needs
For job. And then here we are again
Let's take another form field. New Date Tax
Let's give it to him. So we will make a new date. So
Here we need to disable if
So if it is a date from today then here
But if you look at it, you will see the past from today.
Date disabled will appear. So Application Deadline
And here is the name we have given
Last Date to Apply because we have
The table in your database is named
In that. Ok? So this happened. come here
Here we are and here we take it.
Form field again because for skills.
We will need skills. Sorry Self
There will be a clue. what will happen here
My? control on dot control dot on change
It will remain mine. Ok? So what is this for us?
Will it remain? Of skill. Ok? Field of skill
Will remain. So basically what did we do inside this?
Already done? Created a separate component
There has been skill input in which when you
If you put comma separate then chips inside it
Will be visible. It means that when you put a comma, it
The skill will be visible as a chip. It
Means that in bandages. So here we have the same
It has been done and bandage has been used. One
Then here comes a set scene. Correct
Is? And then when you're on enter
When you are turning it on, here
The value is being set. Ok? end key
It's like it's going down. So here you are
You will see. So, we're checking that enter
has happened or the comma is suppressed. So we him
What are people doing here trimming?
Set it inside your ad screen.
Are giving. And that's what we saw here.
are also giving. Ok? So here it is
We have also shown that comma separate
You can add it. And that's what we are here for
The value has been looped and shown.
It's a simple component guys. Nothing!
Is. I will enter all this code again in the gate.
Pay. You can take it from there. Ok? So
I close this. And you will come here
So if you look here, how do we
Is it visible from? look at it this way
In Required Skills, if you do this
If I put HTML here, it looks like this.
from JavaScript
Like this. Ok? So you see it here
You can also remove it from here.
So we just added this. If you remove it then
You will be told here Required Skill
You will have to put it in. Ok? Mandatory
That's it. So let's come here. End Form
Field. Ok? I will quickly do this too
I will define it. control
Form Dot Control Powder. Ok? So this
Whose status will remain mine? Now if here
But look. So here the status is open and
This will be my close. Ok? in the last
We could have added a button here.
Are. div leke yahan pe kahan hai div end
We give top to the class border
This. Ok? So a little border from the top
Will be visible. Create job. So this will be mine
button. Ok? So clear that first.
Can. Let's say we don't want to create it.
If so, he can clear it. So we
The simple form that we have there pay form
This form has been taken. So here
Let me show you. This one that we
I have taken the form, what should I do with it?
Gave? Inside that you have the reset function
will be. With that you can do a simple reset.
And the default value is what you provide.
I am doing it. So the form is your reset.
Will go. Ok? If submitted, this is one of our
State in which a false is taken
Is. If I show you. To. So here
Look, right now we have taken a state whose
Inside the default value we have given is false
Is. And when you agree, you will submit it on
If you call the function on submit, then at that time you
What can you do about it? True False Can
yes. So that's what we've done here. If
If it is disabled, as if it is submitted, then I will disable it.
I will do it. And I will show you at that time
Creating. Ok? Job here you say like this
You can find it here at Creating and Then Else
Create job. Ok? So loader we have here
Where did you show it from? Simple Ye Luciter
React which is the normal library of React.
Ok? So this is what we used here.
Is. And if I show you here
You will see something like this: Clear End
Create job. So this will be my form job.
For creation. Ok? And all these
We have already defined the fields here.
It happened guys. Correct and same same we
It is used here. what do we have now
Do you want to do it here? We come here.
And here we will have the form. So
Here I say on submit and f dot
Handle submit. So what do we have inside it?
Have to do it? Let's create an onSubmit function
Here pay cost on submit a submit handler called
or whatever name you want to give, submit it
The handler says it.
submit handler ok? And quickly I
Let me define this also. default
Value. Ok? So, will this be ours?
Guys? onSubmit handler function. When submit
The handler function will be called on click,
So we made it true. which we state
It has been taken, we had taken this state,
We had marked it as false by default.
Correct this state and then we
What did I do here? I simply checked which
The last date is less than our new date is
So what we did was we simplified it to manual.
Having a deadline future by setting an error
I should have set the error from here
Manual error if I am setting this
In this way we can do it in any field
for end assume if this is not an error
So below will come you accessing the form data
You can end the form when your form is here
Pay data created and APS accessed
Go and you can reset this form
or wherever you want to send it to
You can send it there. So let's do one thing
Let's get the data quickly. Ok? So we
What did you do here? Simple, nothing right now
Kiya hua guys on submit and layer pe ye jo
We had taken this falls upstairs.
So we made it true here.
And finally we have it faked.
Is. And here we checked a condition.
It has happened that our last date to apply
If you believe me, it is less than current date
So what have we done here? For him
Set manual error for that field.
For this field. Ok? last date
For applying. That is, I told here
given that
Deadline Must Be Feature. Ok? end return
I did it from here. Ok? don't come in
He will get it. And suppose everything is correct then
What did we do here? Simple form data
We have just stored the data in it. him you
You can use it and insert it into the API.
Yes, in your database. Ok? and then when
If it is successful then you can save your form.
Reset it. And Elsewhere, whatever catches you
I have to do it. Finally, we did it
It has happened. Ok? So now let's do one thing.
Guys, let's save this in the database.
Let's take it. So we do one thing for that.
Are. So we already have job action here
I had created my own server action. So the server
For action, first I use pay here
The server will have to use this directive.
Correct. Then this will become our server action.
Otherwise, you will get this error when you use it.
This in the client component. Well then? So
We imported it here. End
We can call it here. So
What should I say here? cost
Response
Await and Create Job and Create Job
What will people do? will import it here
But. We will make it unsinkable.
Ok? A sink and what do we have to give it
Is? Job data. So I say cost
Job data is equal to this data. Because
We have all the job data right here.
Will come. When we submit our forms
because where did we call this
Has it happened? In your own. Correct. so we have
Job data will come here and what will we do?
It has to be passed to the Recruiter ID that who is
If he is creating jobs then how does he help us?
You will get the relationship we have built here.
Tha Guys what about this table with this
we had made it, we had made it, that its
The recruiter ID, this ID will be its
This will be its Recruiter ID correct
So if you see here, we have a relation
Created ID and Recruiter ID Correct
So if we take his ID here
So that's what the recruiter ID will be correct so we
People pay here
I would say user
Is equal and I would say you user store
Correct, we made this and we are here
What can I do on S
I user store correct and here we go
What can we say about this, what do we have?
Here we have entered the recruiter ID, so here we
People will say recruiter ID and user dot
dot ID this okay so this
It's perfect. We will do it here
It is like this. Ok? So we made this
Gave. And we will pass it on.
Ok? So look what we have here
The data will be of type . So here's something like this
The data will be of type . Status, Skill, Last
Dates, experiences, all of that. Ok? So
If we look here, here you
You will see if we edit this, edit
Table. So you can see it here. Ok?
Did we miss a status here? it
Gotta text.
And here and ours which is required
We have experience with this too, we will text it.
They say here. Ok? because we are people
We are taking it in text there only.
To the experience. Correct. So if you're here
You will see what we have here.
Ok? Experience Required
Text here string here. So here
But we did it. And now we are going to
Let's test it. So before that, we are here.
Let me do one thing. So here we have
It will come to pay. So what should I say here? If
Response dot status Assume if true
It means that true, it means that he created
will be. So what will we do here? I
I will say toast to this, they should import it again
Are. Reactify is what we've added as our plugin.
This is called dot success. Success
What will we say here? Job
created
Successfully. Ok? Create a job here
Done. Now suppose when the job is created then
What will you do? First, what should you do that
This is a form, reset it. How to reset
do? Simple form of this which we have
The wrap is taken
End Reset and Default Value Already
Look, we have made this above.
Default value here so here when
If you come, this is our default value.
Meaning that the default we have set inside it
It is the same as it was done and we reset it.
I called Reset and we gave him this pass.
default value it means that our
The form that we have filled up should be reset.
If he goes then what will we do in the end
One more thing we should do here is that when
If create is created then where does it go?
Should I go? ps router use router from
Next navigation when the job is created
So where should this go? those with jobs
If I go there on the page, what am I doing here?
Will I do it? Where is router.push? Job
Space. Ok? So shall we see that?
Ours will be here. We can also see the path
Will take. And what else will happen here?
Ah here toes dot error and rest dot
Message. Ok? Whatever the message is, it will be visible
Will go. And we will remove this here.
From. And ours is ready here.
Is. Ok?
So now let us test it. So I came
Think everything is right. Our job creator
We did. And then I think all this
Guys is perfect. Ok? So once upon a time
Let's test it once. will see that
If there is any problem. Ok? So
Here we have kept it open.
If we need dummy text, I
I say
software Engineer. Now I'm here for this
I copy it from. dummy text here
So we paid here. and if assume
That you should use all this, headings etc.
So I say here's something for
For example, I say heading and I
I select this. And I am here
I say H3 we will need. So like this
You can take it from. And I say here
Creating List One and so on in the list
If yes, then we will do it here and this will happen.
will it go to list two
List three is like this okay then I would say
I am going to give it Delhi and full time minimum.
If you want a salary, I would have said this much.
I say this much at most
It will happen and the deadline will be extended.
Let's do 31 of the application, okay and end
Skill so I say simple here.
html css ss
JavaScript End
Super base status will remain open and I think
We have filled everything. So if we people
Create here also. So I say
Create Job Let's see what happens. Job
Our creation has been done. And we are here
Where did you go? Right now we are
went to the dashboard because we found its path
Did not give. But it redirects from there.
Went. And we also send you a toast message here.
Got to see it. So we did this here.
Diya and Hamara Yahan Pe Perfect. Now we
What can people do about it? Job pages
To go to pay. So what do we have here?
Pay? See.
So whatever happens here. So first we
What do I have to do here? Now I am here
What will I say to this? Recruiters. Ok? So
I say here recruiters and
Jobs. So where will it go? Recruiter
On the page with the list of jobs. So
Now I think this is perfect for us.
Create job is able to do this from here. End
This is our right. Ok? So here you go
Where was it needed? Recruiters Job A Job Yes.
So there are jobs, right? Ok? So here
Came to All Jobs. So here we are
List of all your jobs
We can show it here. Correct? So
This is our job creator.
Ours is ready. It's fine now? job's hum
People also show the data. The job we
We have created that list here.
Let's get it done too. So let's do one thing. I
I say close others. Ok? close tax
Let's take this. So what is he saying? Ok
Don't save. Ah, so we have removed this from ours.
We give. Ok? So where do we have
Is? Here we have it inside the app,
It is private, there is a recruiter, there is a job. And this
This is our page. Ok? where we are from
People will list all their jobs. Ok?
So let's do one thing. Ah here I am a
I make components. Ok? So here
Ok? I say new file. Job
Listingsx ok? So I say cost
A: Let's do one thing, yes, cost job.
The listing is fine, so this will be my job.
Component of listing okay so a this now
We'll see what date comes, okay, near it.
What date will come, but for now we are here.
Let's do one thing here, simple return
And here we take our div.
Class
Space
And let's do this and do a little work.
Yes, let's make it four. Ok? Here
Pay div take end class
Let's put it between the flax. Ok?
Here we dive into new jobs.
Ok? So what will remain of me? a kind of
Heading from. So I say export.
Default end this is our job listing. This
What are we doing here simply for now?
We do? Let's import it. Ok?
End the job listing like this. Ok?
So if we look here. So here
We should see job listings. And here
What do we see? Post new job.
So what do we do with this? A
Class
MX auto tax. And this is what we will see
Something like this. And I say drink
Y
something like this is fine
And this is how we will see it, so I think
perfect that's okay so job listing
Manage and monitor all the job postings and
Post New Job If you want to post a job
So if you click here, where will it go?
On our job post page, we have posted a job
Creation wala already made, okay so this
So we did it and here we are.
Due, we take classes here.
Rounded MD end is called border.
We give a little bit in it. here
We take our own tables. Table
Where do we get A from? sets here
That means we take the table from the UI. More
It will be better there. Ok? So here I am
I say on
Table. So here is the table. Ok? Here
We can add it simply.
Where did you go? Ah, here's the table.
And come here and go to the terminal. Add
We will do it here. So here we are
Pay table will also be added. So here we are
If people import then we have it here
Here comes the table and here. Ok? Here
Let us take the table header. Ok?
You will get all these components when you use a table.
If you install the component, you will see it here
You will find everything. and you install
do it. Took the table header. And I am here
I say table lights. Ok? So this will remain
What about me? A our table header. So if
You will see that we remove it here.
Like this. Ok? This is how our
The table header will appear. Ok? Header. End
Our column inside this will be Job Title,
Location, Type, Salary Range, When Posted,
What is the status of the job? And what is inside it
The actions that will be taken for example for the job
You can edit, view,
You can also delete it. Correct? So, all of that
There will be actions in it. So this will be my table.
Header end here will be my table body.
Ok? This is where my table body will be. So
Let us do one thing. Here we are
You can fetch your data. So I am a
I work. Use effect. So here we are
Sorry use effect from.
We take the use effect. And sorry.
Yes. So, this is my use effect. Import
This will have to be done from here with React.
Use Effect is Guys Use Effect
Okay, tell him that's why we're here.
What will have to be done? You will have to use the client.
That's why he's causing problems, okay?
We did it here and here we are
It is said that cost
Fetch Jobs
And what will we do from here, wait?
I will give it an end here sorry ah yes ok
Is. After waiting, we will tell you the cost here.
Or let us do one thing first. here
We write try catch. Ok?
So I say try
There will be an error in the crash. Ok? And finally.
So finally. So let's do one thing here.
I say cost
Set loading
Use State
End Falls. Ok? So here as soon as we
If people call this, then our here
What will happen? This will be true. and finally
What should be in it? These falls. Ok?
Like this. Ok? what is this saying
Us? Here we have to write async and not
Await. Ok? So this will be mine. And here
But what will we do? Now Cost Response
Is equal to a wet patch jo we have here
I had made it here in job action so
Created this was our sorry here and
This was Get Job By ID Edit Delete And
Get Recruiter Jobs so here we are
what will you do oh sorry I was here right yes
Here we will call it S here.
We will import it, why should we pass it?
Will it be necessary? We have to pass this
Recruitment Recruiter ID. So that
What will be the Recruiter ID? We are already
I know. So what will I do here?
cost
Here I call it user is = you
User Store. Ok? End as I User
Store. Ok? So this is what we said and I
What should I pass him here? user dot
ID. Ok? I passed this. End
If
Response dot status assume status will be
So what will happen? Success. So here we are
What can be done? Find your job here
You can get all the jobs. So here I am
Pay kahta hoon cost
jobs set jobs is equal use state and
I will give him a blank. Right now array
I will come here. It means it's a success
Has gone. So here I will say rest dot
data because we are here to date data
I am giving it to you, see here.
In the data, we have response dot here.
What date did you give? It means that data is our feature
Done. Ok? We here at Else
What to do? toast toast again we have here
Imported from . This is what we have in the library
Installed Click Package and Dot
Success Sorry Error Something Went Wrong Say
Let's give it to him. Ok? So here we are
As soon as the data comes, we will do it here.
We'll take it and then we'll have a toast here again
We will come here and copy this.
There is an error dot here.
I will message him, he will not do it.
Later, okay, so we did it and
What will we do to simplify it here?
We will fetch the job, okay it is ours
The job will be fetched and what can we do?
I will give this job to
We will pass the jobs here. Ok?
So, he will say that we did not get any job.
remained. So, I would say here that jobs will come.
We have. Again we need to type define this
Will have to do it. So, I say here
Interface and I would say interface jobs
Props and what do we have here?
Will you come? So, will Jobs. So, its type will be
I
Job. Ok? Ok? We already have this
It was made there. Ok? Ok? This much
We will give it right now. But this will be mine
Array of object correct. So that's why I
Gave the array here. And I will tell this
I hope brother, this will be of this type. So
Now he will accept things. than we
What can people do here? in loop
You can show it by running it. So here we are
What will people say? Job dot length a greater
If the day is zero, then what are we here for?
Can you do it? A
Yes. So here we can show our A
There is what we have to show. Ok? Or else
We'll show you what we have to show you in Else.
We are here. Ok? So here the diff
We will see what they will show us now. No Job Count
Let's write it here also. Ok? End
What do we have to do here? So here
But we have our own again, I say here
Table Job This one is our job dot map
Let's do this and then we'll have it here.
jobs sorry this job is fine and here we
People can write down what they will do.
Our so here what should I say on the table row
which this is my table row table row this was
Our table row is okay and what's in it
I will say that I, so what what
Let's give my job dot ID. Unique
Will have to give. So we have job dot ID
It is already there. So we provide that to him
I will get it done. Let's take the table cell. here
We already have it
Div dot dot dot here. Ok? So this
We have shown the table cell here. Whose
For? For your job title. Ok? So
It means that the job title will look like this.
And so this will be mine, which one? of job title
Cell of your table. Ok? So this will be the job
Title this one. Ok? In the same way I
Let me take another one here. table cell ok
Is. What do we have to show here?
Location. So here on Div
Dot location. So what will remain of me?
The one with the location. So we have this here on job.com
Location shown location. Ok? So we
What did you do here? Your location here
I showed it. So here we have this one
Took icon from Lustful Act. So here
But what you will see is this one from the Lustful Act.
Icon and then your job location. So if
Save us guys. So here it is something like this
Will be visible from. Software Engineer These Skills
Is. I mean showing three skills. His
Later we are showing dot dot. End
Where is the location? Whoever is here
The location will be. And then we are here right now.
And let's show it first. So I say
Hoon here table cell than dev job type.
Ok? So here we have shown the job type.
Gave. Here we have to show
Variant. So variants do one thing.
Variant Normal, we do one thing
Let us define this. so we have
It is useful here, isn't it? So do it here
Are. Ok? So I say export.
an export function
And what is this? A what is this? a job
Type. Ok? So here it comes to us
Type. This will be a string. Here we are
Will install switch case. The switch will come here
Type. Will come here. Here I will be
Secondary. Ok? So this one is secondary.
We just keep the beans here. So this
There will be job type variant. In a way what
will be? Suppose that when it is full time then some
This way the default return will occur. Part
If there is time, something like this secondary here
There will be payback. So we have a job here.
We do. Let's copy this. here
Paste and import it
First. And we will pass it here.
We give. This job dot job type. So like this
From. Ok? So if you look, so here
Pay will show something like this full time. Some?
Like this. So kind of fancy type
To show. So we showed it here
Like this. And then we give it another thing
You can do that which is just shown in full half time.
Used to be. If you assume that this is constant
Put it in and put the switch case in this way and end
Assume that when it is full time then the icon
Remove it and show it like that full time. Correct
Is? So we can do this. But right now
We keep it with us. So here I am again
I take the table cell. Ok? D here we are
What will people do? I will show you my A. What
Is it ours? After this salary range it means that
Mean and Max we have to show both.
So let's do one thing. a function for that
Let's make it. Ok?
Export function so dot to local screen
Let's tell him this. Ok? So we got this gate
Made of salary range. And do one thing
Are. I say here, get sorry here.
PayGate imports salary ranges. End
What do we have to pass here? Who
We made it here on Mean and Max so
What do we have? Jobs.meansSaleJobs
If we pass this dot max sale then our
What should be seen near there, here in this
In such a way that the salary is between so much and so much
Salary will be available in the range. Ok? like this
And again, we take the table here.
Sale status. We are here to do our job
Will show the status. And again we have here
What do I have to show? Variant. So Again
For this we do one thing. Ah one
Let's create the function. Ok? So here
Export
function get job
Variant. Ok? It will come to us here
There will be status. The string will come to us and
Here switch secondary. Ok? So this
Same ah so here we have the same now which this
It was made in the same way that we are here
They are also taking status. and get a job
Variant here we call it end
Job dot status. Ok? So here we are
Passed it. And if we come here
So what we see is that it's open like this.
From. Ok? And this is perfect right now. So
Let's refresh it once. So who is this
Is there any error guys? Which one is this? Ok. say this
You can't use divs instead of tables
Inside. So people will see that. Later
Will remove this div. Here we have some more
Will have to use it. So we have to work on that
I will have to. We have shown the status. Now
What do we have to show? here a
Status a posted date we had to show. Ok
We made a mistake. One more to show us
It will fall here. So let's do one thing. This
Let's copy. Let's paste it. And this
We remove it. Looks simple here
We give. I say job dot dot
Created at we show it. End
Here it is. And here it says
Export
Function
Get date and here we go
We will get a date string which will be
This string type. Ok? And is it okay? So
This will be my formatted
Date. Ok? So now we have it here
Let's use it. Simple, no more problems
Should not happen. I use it here
I have been. Dot created a created at okay.
I think we typed it here.
What's nearby? Created at not created
It will be et. So created at will be here.
Ok? So I think this is perfect. If we
If people look now, we have a view here.
Needed Yes, this is what it looks like. Now we the people
Let's create our action here. Table
Cell End Here Div W Here
We also increase its width to four. So
Will this remain mine? Actions button. Correct
Is? It's simple. button now anything we have in this
It is not written. So here we have
There is view, edit, and delete. these three
We have action. So what we have now
Does it look like this? So let's do one thing
Are. I will add a class here.
Am. We will have class here.
Class name then I say cursor
Pointer. Ok? Simply add it to everything
Are. So basically the hand will be visible in it when someone
If he overdoes it. Ok? So do it here too
Are
Pointer. Ok? Now if you look at it like this
Will be visible from. Ok? Which better to do here also
We will give it. Here we have a button
I will make this the last of all jobs, sorry.
debtor
Pointer. Ok? This is how we here
It will appear that this is a better way. Ok? So
Now we have so many jobs here.
If yes, they will be listed here. Ok?
And here I say on
Where to click, what will you do on click?
Here on Const
What should I do here? ok one thing
Basically what do we do here?
We will send you here
a create job
handler which will be a function okay end
We will call you here when it happens.
This is on click
Okay here, so here we are near here.
We will do it and we will tell you about it here.
We will tell you that brother, this will also come to us as the
Props. So we passed this. So now
What is there here? It's perfect. Ok? So
We can define it here.
Where to create job handler? So here
Pay. Ok? So what will I do here?
Let's turn this off.
const create job handler end here pay end
Simple, what will we do here?
Basically we do one thing here.
I say cost
End Use Router from Next Navigation End
The router will push it. Where?
Where will this go? Where do we need to send it?
So where are we here? already
I am on the job. So I'll tell you to go for it
Where to go? Create Pay. Ok? Job
Create and I will pass this here.
Give.
Ok? And what will happen here? Here
But what will we have? It will be here
Recruiters.
Ok? Create here. So what about here
will be? When you click on this, it will go somewhere
Will this get pushed on? On this. So here when
Let us refresh once. So now when I
If I click here, where do I go?
Will I go? On the job creation page. Ok?
And when someone is created from here, then where will it be?
Will he go away? On your list page.
Ok? And here he dates her
It will be visible after refreshing. So it is ours
We will remove the action for now.
Are. Ok? Let's remove it. So this is our
The listing is done. So we have a
Let's work. We will close this as well.
Are. And here we have all this action.
It is there now. Ok? So we have a task to edit.
We do. Let's work on this first. So
So let's come here. Ok? A here
This is how we create it, isn't it?
I will create a handler here. Ok?
Edit Job Handler. Ok? Edit Job Handler
It will be mine. And where will the job go here?
Edit is here, inside the job, edit and
Here we have to pass its ID
Okay, so here it will come to me ID and
Which will be string type and I here
Let's do one simple thing, use back tick.
Let's take it here and here and I
What will I do here, pass this ID to him?
Give. okay so the job that he edit
He will use that data there.
Will go. So let's do one thing, let's do it a little bit
Let's format it. here and I
Here I say edit job handler. Here
But let's pass it. Ok? So here
But let's move on. Again, we would say here
Yes, this will also be a function.
And this is a type defined basically
We assumed that the function would be of type . Butt returns
Will not do anything. It will remain void. Ok? So
Edit will be the job handler. And simply we are the people
What will you do here? where is it here now
Is my action gone? Here it is. On click, we
People here. Ok? Yes. On click we
People will pass it by. Ok? So here
But when we come, we will refresh and see.
what if we do it on edit
Is he going to edit or do we have to do something else?
Will have to. Let's see. So this is ok ok ok. Now
We were not allowed to pass here. Basically we
What to do guys? Here here here we
This has to be called. And here we get a job
Dot ID has to be passed. And what is he saying
Do we have it? Expected zero.
Expected zero not a
One second. Yes. So he will come here. So here
What will happen when it comes to me? ID
String.
And here if we back it up
Refresh it once. And I'm here
Should I edit it? So where did it go?
JobsEdit. ok I forgot to put the slash which is
It's the right thing. We did not give a slash here.
These. Ok? So if you put a slash here
So where will you go? Let's see where
Let's go? Edit job wala pe. Ok? Now
Edit the job that we created here.
A edit sorry this one edit page this one. So
What do I do here, that job?
I'll call the listing guy right away.
For
No job a create what is our a sorry
Let's take a second and look here.
Did we create this job here?
I'm calling the form, I'm doing a job.
Sorry for the form
We would have called the job form here.
Yes and here it is okay so we have job form
and if we just
If you look at it, we have something like this
Will go. But we have this URL and this
It is visible. So, from this data we have
People can patch any job.
Correct. So we will do that now. So this
I am going to edit now, so I will do this after doing it.
Diya here. Ok? This is the one who creates
Was. Ok? But this edit of ours
It will be a second. This is our edit.
will be. So send a type to us here
We will type it. Ok? so type this
What will happen in the case? If going from edit then
It will be edited. End
What do we have to do here? Data also
Let's do one thing. They just send the data.
Ok? So let's do one thing. I am here
I say you should make the export default limitless.
Are.
Ok? End Cost Data Get Job By ID.
We had already created our own job action. End
Will he come to us here? Params. Correct
Is? Because we are sending people here.
This is the parameter we are sending here, ID.
So it will come to us here. So here
I will send it. But first we wait for this
We do it. Ok? End
Here we say if the data
Dot status assume that is not true. So
What will we do? Simple and
data dot ah data dot data sorry rush kar
Let's give it to him. Ok?
And let's put rest here rest dot
Data Dot
What will we do if the length becomes zero?
People return from here, simple one
Let's take the div and I'll say no to it.
No job found okay and import this
Let's take it, this is imported ID for us.
You will have to pass it which we have here
will fairs come
And let us do one thing, I define it here.
I do it
Interface
A edit props. Ok?
What will we say here? In this
What will come to us? whose ID will be
The type will be params here.
Whoever has a promise will end here
What? The ID will be of string type. End
I will tell it that its type will be
These. Ok? Ok? It means that this
There will be a promise.
So here we call it cost ID.
and await
Payms. So I removed my ID from Param.
I have been. I am passing the ID to him. Correct
Is? ID. So it will say that you string
Is. You are sending the number. You are doing this.
So
Ok?
So I did this. Get Job ID Tax
Gave. I don't have a job. So I
Sent this here. And then we are here
What will you say on this?
Job
What do we have here in the default value?
Will you give? Job. Ok? So we passed it
Given the job form. So if we have both of these
I passed it here. So come here in this
Let's go once. And here we have
Will come. So basically here is the interface
The job props will come to us of type string
will be. And what else do we have here?
Pay? A second one we have this default one
This is called value values. And here
If it happens on this then it will be okay. But this will happen
A of this type. Ok? This will be an I job
Type of. Ok?
And I will tell you that whoever comes here
Type
The default value will be its type
Basically what this will be is a sorry for us here
I will have to do job data, sorry for this.
Let us say here that we have the job data right.
Because it is already defined. So
Here I send it this way. And this
What is he telling us? The gate is saying
Job Buy It. What is he saying? A Cannot
Find Job. If you can't find it, OK.
I will send him a reply saying sorry. Ok?
And now he must be telling us what all
saying status ok response dot
Sorry, we have to send the data here.
Will have to. Then he will go and accept everything. So
Now we also have type coming here.
End job data is also coming. So now we are
You can work here. Ok? a job o
[ __ ]
Guys this is what happens so let's name it
We call this A-form data.
No, is there any form data here?
The form data is already there, it is not here.
So here we call it
Form data OK We will send the form data
People from there could have said this much here.
is this form data form data okay so
Now it is perfect, we will have the type.
What type and where is it coming from? From Create
It can come here or from edit.
So, this is our end form data.
Near. Ok? Let's come here. So, a job
We do. What do we have to do? This
Will have to update. So, what are we here for?
Can you do it? So, let's do one thing. I
I say use effect here.
And it will come to us here. Ok?
So, what will I do? If Type Equal Edit
End of data. Ok? If I have it then
What am I going to do? Form dot reset.
Ok? So you can reset the form.
We people. And in reset we are here
What to do? This is the form data
We will give him this form data.
Ok? Sorry. This is how we will do it
That like this. Ok?
And what is this telling us? This is saying
That's ok. So let's do one thing. here we
People also give default values. So
And this will tell us that it could be of this type
is string assignable to type date and somewhere
There is a string somewhere and there is a date, that is the problem.
Must have been. Ok? So basically if we
If you look here, this is the date. We people make this
Let's string it now. Ok? And this
He will call us again. So we see all that
Will take. A so perfect for now. So
If I give it to you this way, then take it.
I will take it now. Ok? But give it to us here
You will have to specify that the type of form data when this
Change Ho and Form. So when these three changes
If so, it should update automatically.
Ok? So this is ours, if we now
See. So if I refresh this now
So let's see if the data is fetched now.
No.
Ok. So come here once. here
Let's see if we have received the data.
No. First, the data is our API call.
Gone is the guise. Let's do one thing we have
Here on A here on we have job response
The dot must have come in the data. I hope then here
He has come here. And here we will have
Form data. So let's do one thing. see
What is there here?
End Form Data in Form Data once
Let us refresh it. Ok?
So here in the job form we have this
Has come. Ok? Ok. OK OK OK OK.
Because this is an array of objects. So now
For this we do one thing. I this
I am giving the object with zero. Ok?
So he will not accept it now. A here
We basically do one thing. Let's go now
If I change it here, then that is for type
It will create trouble. So I'm going to do something here.
I will give it to him. Here we are for now
Send zero. Data with zeros. Correct
Is? I am sending it for now. But
We will see now. Look, he has come, right? So Sarah
Something came to us. here we have
Look at all the data we filled in.
He came here and felt it with us. End
What can he do from here? Create
Can update. We will change this too now
Can do. Because we have the type
Already. And I can change this too.
Am. I can change this also. Correct?
So we will do that.
Ok. So we did this. This is what we have
The date is coming, so here we are
I am doing the get edit job. So
Here we call it dot single.
That will be much better. And we have here
We won't need to pass this
Have to give zero. And here we also need length
Will not get it. Now you will get simple data. So
Let's not mark this one too. Ok? So I came
Think now if we look here then this
It's perfect. And then what are we here for?
Can you do it? Now we have here we
Where did you come from? A job form, right? yes here
Pay. So here's the submit handler. and this
So what can we do here?
Look, this is the title we have.
A here A so here we have. So I
What can I do here? Type. Ok?
I call this type.
Equal equal, suppose it is edited, then what?
do you
Else show this here or else this
show okay okay like this here we
what will you show
Edit
job is ok edit job and same here also
can you show it okay show it here
You can fill the details here.
to edit
So in this case you can show it simply
This is what I call different text.
from end I will say type if equal end
Equally, suppose it's an edit, what do you do?
Show me something else here, otherwise what is there
Let it be like this, okay, say it like this
Let's give this what I call an update here.
The details for the job posting look exactly like this:
Let's tell him that this will happen and it will come.
My perfect. And in the same way we have
There is also a Pay button here. Ok? So here
We have a button, where did the button go here?
Our?
This one. Ok? So here we are showing
I'm creating jobs for now. Correct
Is? So we can change this also.
Here I say if type equal. Correct
Is? I'm saying edit. Edit is here
Show on
Show me the submission. Ok? Show this in Else
Sorry I think that's how we do it. Ok?
So this will be mine. Ok? then it will be submitted
So we can show it like this. Otherwise, we
People can show it here. And then here
Pay we have this creating. End
Here, what can we do in that simple case?
Will you give? What do we have here? creating
If it is there then we will leave it as it is.
Creation will continue here. here
We will say updating.
We will remove this. This is our perfect one.
What is left for us now? Now it remains for us that when this
If it is submitted then where will it be submitted
Submit? The submission will happen here only, right? Here it is
We have our submit handler here. right here
He will come to pay. He will come here to do this.
Job Date Our everything will remain here. here
It is happening to us
Which will be an add update. Correct. So right here
We can do that thing too. So right here
We already have the type. Here if
Type is Equal and Equal Edit. So you are this
Do what you have to do in Else
Here. And let us do it like this. Correct
Is? So what do we offer here?
Here they do one thing. This is how
We will have to write. Ah let race equal two
Let's just tap it for now. Ok?
And we will define it as any. But
Let us give this here right now. A
Sorry and we will throw this out as well.
Are. Let's simply keep it out here.
Ok? This will be common for everyone. That too us
People will change. And we will have this
Here. Ok?
Let's put it this way. And here at this
Kind of because we already have race defined.
Already done. If there is an edit, edit it here.
When the job is edited then what will we have?
Will I have to do it here? Look here we
This was our editing job, where did it go? These
remained. So we also have to pass the job ID here.
Will have to do it. So how do we pass here?
Can I get a job ID? So where did it go here?
Sorry, this is not it. A, where did this go? Sorry
A is this it? This is an edit job, so the job data
So we are already giving it. So we have a job
You will have to pass ID. How do we get Job ID?
can give? We have user dot ID
It is already there. So that's our a sorry no
You will have to provide your job ID. So
Job data and a do one thing. These
Job Date: Here we have a job.
There will be no data, no job data. So here
What will we have that we have now?
The form will be data. form data this one
We have the form data here. So
Form data ID. Ok? So this will happen. End
Whatever we have here in edit job
This data will be gone. And but we have here
But what do we have to do here?
Let's work. What data do we have
Is he accepting this? Accept this
What are you giving us? An edit.
Payload in the job. In the payload we have this
It should be of type . So
We also have to pass the recruiter ID in it.
It will be needed, which is ok, we have already done it.
So we can pass the job data here.
We give. It's simple. Yes, very simple
Is. A job ID is done. A ok yes this is not
have to do it because we are there
Not destructuring. Ok?
Yes, he is telling the string and number. They
Ok. He will see the rest later. But
When you come here, we will be here.
If you are doing numbers then you will have to do strings
us in the case of edit job because he
what is it saying string is undefined also
It is possible This is why it is said that
It can also be undefined that it
This will not be undefined. So let's leave it
This will not be undefined because
When it comes to us in an edit case,
We will always have the data in this. So
This will end here
Let Message Is Equal to Type Equal End
If it is an equal edit, then please show something here.
like this
Job is fine, this means we send this message
I'll give it here okay perfect and then this
Everything will be the same where the push is happening
The update will go there after it is created.
So if we refresh here,
I will do it. Ok? This is our job
Near. And from this I am removing a list
I am this.
It means that now we have only two. End
From here I am removing the CSS. Ok?
So look, we have two things here right now.
We updated. Ek to skill and ek hi
Is. So if I submit here. See
We have a submit showing up. Edit job view
Used to be. And now I say this from here
Submit. Let's see what he says. Correct
Is? So let's do one thing. Open this also
Let's take it. somewhere in some network
If there is any problem, we will take care of that too.
Ok? So let's come here. I am saying
I am submitting. So Updating and Job Updated
Successfully our job has been updated.
And if we edit this now,
What will happen? Let's see here. went here
Only two lists are visible. CSS not showing
Used to be. So it means that our updated
Guys, you are doing a perfect job. Ok?
So our update job is also working correctly.
Now and I think this is perfect. delete job
We also make it quickly. So,
We are closing this. Our edit
So it worked. Job Delete Job Already
We have an action created here.
Whoever accepts it will have a job ID.
So let's copy this. We have here
Isn't it on? So let's make it here. So I
I say cost and I am saying this
that delete job handler. Ok?
And I call this a sink.
And here I say cost race end
Sorry, I deleted it, not edited it.
Delete this also, accept this job ID, right?
Yes, sorry, I copied the edit and deleted it.
job I am saying here and this
We are importing it, what do we have?
If you want to do job ID then it will come here.
Pass ID
Which will be any string or number.
If there is only job ID number then I will pass it.
what is this telling us that yes
This will be the number. Ok?
There will be a number. So I am passing this on. End
Now look I'm saying if rest dot a
Sorry, I will have to wait for this.
Ok? So what will I say to this? Rest
dot status if suppose it is true then what
Will you do it? Suppose delete is true then that means
That job got deleted. So what will you do now
You will like the new job. So simple
What should I do? Please call him. So what
Our own job updated app will come
Will go. We will pass it from here.
Delete Job Handler and then click here
Will come to your listing. We tell this to the people
I will give you that sorry
This will happen here. And again it has our
will have job ID and return it provided